Hallo und herzlich willkommen. Hier ist die Freak Show Nummer 297.
Hast du mittlerweile eine Idee, was wir zur 300 machen sollen?
Nie hau. Nein.
Ja, wir sind so unkreativ. Das ist furchtbar. Naja, es wird schon noch was einfallen.
Ja, hallo. Wir sind es wieder. Ich bin's, Tim. Tim Britlaff.
Last time I checked. War es noch so?
Und Roddy ist wieder da.
Ja.
Aus China.
Aus China. Na gut, jetzt schon eine Weile, aber...
Aber du bist wieder da, aus China.
Ja, China ist der Grund, warum ich zweimal nicht in der Sendung war.
Ja. Normalerweise liefern die ja schneller.
Naja, das erste Mal hätte ich quasi vom Flughafen direkt hier in die Meta-Ebene kommen müssen.
Das hätte ich vielleicht gerade noch so zum Beginn der Sendung geschafft.
Aber nach 10, 12 Stunden Flug und 6 oder 7 Stunden Zeitunterschied,
Jetlag und so weiter, dachte ich so, ach, das wollt ihr alle nicht.
Genau, bei der letzten Sendung hast du da noch so ein China-Virus ausgesessen,
den wollten wir auch nicht haben hier im Studio.
Ja, so Reste davon hört man vielleicht noch.
Okay, Hauptsache es ist nicht neuartig.
Also zumindest keiner der Tests, die ich gemacht habe, hat ihn irgendwie erkannt Okay.
Oh Gott Covid-25 So und Ralf ist nicht da,
der hat keine Zeit und ist von daher auch entschuldigt, aber dafür haben wir
Luca wieder dazu geholt Guten Abend Auf dem Remote-Schirm hier Genau.
Zur Vorsicht vor Roddy Ja.
Stimmt.
Mir geht man besser aus dem Weg.
Ja, Zoom ist der moderne Mundschutz.
Das war er vorher schon.
Ja, aber es ist trotzdem modern. Also es ist definitiv...
Die letzten fünf Jahre.
Man isoliert sich einfach immer weiter voneinander und alles wird irgendwie
so total virtuell und manchmal frage ich mich wirklich, was das irgendwie aus den Leuten macht.
Ich habe... Guck mal, ich habe vorhin klicke ich auf meinem Touchpad rum,
Und das Touchpad klickte auf einmal nicht so richtig.
Dann habe ich mir das angeguckt und habe festgestellt, dass unten der Boden sich herauslöst.
Und ich habe das erste Mal in meinem Leben eine dicke Batterie.
Ein Spicy Pillow.
Nennt man das so?
Ja.
Spicy Pillow.
Eine dicke Batterie.
Wenn du dir die so anschaust, dann sehen die aus wie so ein aufgeblasenes Kissen.
Ja.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall hat das Trackpad jetzt, sagen wir mal,
zwei bis drei Grad mehr Winkel als im Auslieferungszustand.
Ja, es federte auch so ein bisschen.
Oh ja, oh ja.
Ja, ja, das fühlt sich nicht gut an.
Nicht gut an, nein.
Kippelt es schon, wenn man drauf drückt?
Wenn man ganz hinten drauf drückt, kippelt es.
Ja, sehr.
Ich hatte das mal mit einem MacBook Pro, das war ein Arbeitsgerät,
das lag immer nur auf dem Schreibtisch und war eigentlich immer zugeklappt.
Und irgendwann habe ich es dann mal aufgeklappt und gemerkt,
warum kippelt das Ding so?
Warum kippelt das? Liegt da irgendwas drunter unter dem MacBook?
Da habe ich gesehen, oh kacke, das ist irgendwie bestimmt einen halben Zentimeter
oder fast einen Zentimeter aufgebläht an der Ecke. Nicht so cool.
Ich habe irgendwann mal in der Firma ein Android-Test-Device zu unserer IT gebracht,
weil das jetzt auch schon deutlich aufgebläht war. Es hielt gar nicht mehr so richtig zusammen.
Und die haben mich angeguckt wie so ein Mondkalb. So nach der Art,
wieso bringst du das uns? Wir wissen doch auch nicht, was wir tun müssen.
Aber naja ja also ich muss mir wohl ein neues kaufen ich überlege gerade,
es ist schwarz das heißt ich habe das irgendwann mal ja.
Aber kannst du nicht den Akku tauschen?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Aufhebeln, gucken, was draufsteht und gucken, ob du sowas nachbestellen kannst.
Ja, aufhebeln habe ich schon probiert. Da bin ich irgendwie gerade trotz iFixit
nicht so richtig dazu gekommen.
Mal schauen, wie ich das Problem löse.
Zwar sich das Problem hier von alleine löst. So, ja. Also, was ist denn passiert?
Wir waren alle irgendwie weg und wie schon erwähnt, Roddy, du warst ja in China.
Warum warst du in China?
Ich war in China, weil dort ein Chorfestival stattgefunden hat.
Irgendwie Beethoven Festival oder so nannte sich das.
Die Chinesen, die wollten halt unbedingt dann auch unseren Chorleiter als Juror
haben und der hat dann vorgeschlagen, seinen Chor gleich mitzubringen und da
waren die ganz begeistert und dann sind wir da hingefahren.
Also ich meine, man wird ja jetzt als Chorleiter nicht mal so eben eingeladen,
zumindest nicht nach China.
Die genauen Beziehungen und was da abgelaufen ist, kann ich dir jetzt nicht sagen.
Ist nicht irgendwie berühmt oder sowas?
Nee, es war schon eher so Vitamin B.
Verstehe, okay.
Aber ja, genau. Und dann war so der Deal, wir bezahlen den Flug und die Chinesen
alles vor Ort, was auch ganz gut geklappt hat.
Wo?
Wo? Ist das groß? Ja, der eine Ort heißt Taizang und der andere Ort heißt Chindao.
Du wirst wahrscheinlich bei beiden Orten nicht wissen, wo das ist.
Taizang ist in der Nähe von Shanghai. Man fährt mit dem Auto so eine knappe Stunde ungefähr.
Schreibst du Taizang?
T-A-I-C-A-N-G.
Okay, Taizang-Shi.
Taizang wird das gesprochen.
Taizang-Shi vielleicht?
Nee, einfach nur Taizang. Das ist, wie gesagt, das ist ziemlich in der Nähe von Shanghai,
und ist so ein Ort, wo sich relativ viele deutsche Firmen niedergelassen haben.
Das Gute ist, dass man da auch, wenn man den Nachmittag frei hat,
auch mal eben nach Shanghai reinfahren kann, was wir auch einmal, zweimal gemacht haben.
Ansonsten ist der Ort so jetzt nicht weiter spannend, gerade weil er auch so
ein bisschen so eine, naja, etwas leere Satellitenstadt ist.
Also so dreispurige Straßen in jede Richtung und eigentlich keine Autos da drauf.
Nicht so richtig.
Also da ist irgendwie nicht viel los. Man hat auch so das Gefühl,
dass die ganzen riesigen Wohnkomplexe, die da gebaut haben, alle zu 90 Prozent leer sind.
Aber ansonsten, ja.
Warst du schon mal da in China?
Ich war noch nicht in China. Okay.
Und die andere Stadt, wo wir waren, Qingdao, die kennt man vielleicht so ein
bisschen durch das Zingtao-Bier.
Das kommt nämlich daher. Das ist auch so ein Ort, der irgendwie so eine deutsche
Geschichte hat und Deutsche haben auch diese Brauerei gegründet.
Das war ganz lustig, weil wir haben da irgendwie versucht, dann auch vor Ort
Bier aus dem Ort zu trinken und alle so, hä, wieso, wir haben doch internationales
Bier, da müsst ihr doch kein chinesisches trinken.
Das ist, aber so schlecht ist es gar nicht. Also das ist jetzt,
man fährt jetzt nicht wegen dem Bier nach China, aber man kann es schon trinken.
Lustigerweise ist das meiste eher so, was man bei uns so als Leichtbier oder
Magerbier kennt oder so, halt so zweieinhalb, drei Prozent.
Also dieses volle fünf Prozent Bier haben die da relativ selten.
Keine Ahnung, angeblich kann der Chinese ja auch nicht so viel Alkohol,
ist vielleicht auch besser so.
Ist generell eine asiatische Schwäche, sagen wir es mal so.
Wobei mir, also wir haben ein paar Deutsche vor Ort kennengelernt und der eine
hat mir versichert, naja es gibt aber Chinesen, die können auch.
Es ist ja so eine Gen-Mutationsgeschichte, so eine Eigenschaft.
Und manche haben es und manche haben es nicht. Und weiß der Geier,
wie sehr sich das mittlerweile so in die Zukunft evolviert hat.
Ja, ähnlich ist es wohl mit der Laktoseintoleranz. Das betrifft irgendwie auch nicht alle.
Der Chinese macht jetzt auch in Alkohol.
Naja, wenn die erstmal richtig saufen, dann haben wir keine Chance.
Ja, wie erzähle ich da weiter? Also Chindao als Stadt,
also während Taizang so ein bisschen so eine irgendwie neu gebaute Mondlandschaft
war und nicht so richtig glaubwürdig war Chindao schon eher eine Stadt,
wo man dann hinfährt und hat so das Gefühl, ja hier leben auch echte Leute.
Also in Shanghai sowieso. Also Shanghai ist ja eine riesige, wuselige Stadt.
Was interessant, was ich interessant fand, war wie leise alle diese Städte waren.
Leise?
Leise, weil der Straßenverkehr relativ leise ist. Du hast einen sehr hohen Anteil an Elektroautos.
Ich habe nur überhaupt ein einziges Moped gesehen, was ein Verbrennungsmotor hatte.
Das habe ich auch schon gehört, dass das bei zwei Rädern echt durch ist.
Und das Krasse ist, die haben halt nicht, wie bei uns, die Fußgängerhupe.
Also in Europa hast du ja unter 30 Stundenkilometer, musst ja das Gefährt...
Ton machen.
Fußgänger-Upe.
Ja, oder das Karkophon oder wie auch immer man es nennt.
Und das haben die dort nicht. Und das ist völlig absurd, wenn du dann siehst,
da stehen da 20 Zweiräder an der Ampel.
Es wird grün. Die sausen alle los und man hört nichts.
Einfach mal gar nichts.
Ja, the power of Elektro.
Und das ist schon so in...
Und die Autos auch.
Die Autos, naja, da ist so der Anteil jetzt grob über den Daumen geschätzt,
irgendwo so bei 50, 60 Prozent.
Die machen auch keinen Ton, also sind nicht verpflichtet, einen Ton zu machen,
wenn sie langsam fahren.
Sind dementsprechend leise.
Man hört dann schon Autos, die einen Verbrennungsmotor haben, raus.
Beziehungsweise wenn dann ein LKW ankommt, dann hast du so das Gefühl,
boah, wer hat denn diesen lauten LKW zugelassen?
Das darf ja wohl so nicht sein. Also es ist wirklich erstaunlich.
Also gerade bei Shanghai, wo du denken würdest, das ist ja eine riesige Stadt,
da tummeln sich so viele Menschen.
Das muss doch ein totales Chaos und Gewühle sein. Nee, es ist relativ leise.
Die hupen auch nicht so laut, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht hat die Regierung da
die Lautstärke der Hupen begrenzt oder so. Ich weiß es nicht.
Es muss ja auch nicht so Terrorhupe sein, wie in Deutschland immer.
Ich meine, hier ist ja, das hatten wir auch schon mal, also in Deutschland ist ja eine Hupe,
wird ja nicht nach STVO zum Warnen benutzt, sondern zum Meinen.
Zum Meinen ist der Audio-Mittelfinger.
Genau. Und deswegen muss die auch so richtig schön kantig und laut sein.
Dabei würde so ein leichtes Miep, Miep völlig ausreichen.
Genau, genau. Also das ist das, was mich zum Verkehr, was ich wirklich spannend fand.
Wir sind auch in Shanghai U-Bahn gefahren.
Das war auch relativ spannend.
Allerdings jetzt eigentlich auch nicht groß anders als irgendwie anderer Städte U-Bahnen,
wenn man mal davon ausgeht, dass die Chinesen sehr gerne irgendwie den Pass
sehen wollen, beziehungsweise andere Personaldokumente.
Das heißt, du kommst in die U-Bahn tatsächlich nicht rein, ohne dein Personaldokument
zu zeigen und mitunter auch nicht, ohne dein Gepäck durchgeröntgt zu haben.
Und du jetzt als Fremdling oder alle?
Wir als Europäer mit dem europäischen Pass hatten da eher einen Vorteil,
weil sie uns relativ locker durchgewunken haben, aber die eigenen Leute,
da gucken sie ganz genau hin.
Und lustigerweise kommst du auch ohne diese Personalfeststellung auch nicht
aus der U-Bahn wieder raus.
Und das gleiche ist beim… Was.
An jeder Haltestelle, wo man ein- und aussteigt, wird der Ausweis gecheckt? Ja.
Es gibt da also das ist eine Frage, die ich nicht beantworten kann, aber ist halt so,
Ja, doch. Ja gut, ich habe jetzt nur drei U-Bahnhöfe gesehen.
Aber da sind noch Millionen Leute irgendwie unterwegs.
Ja, also die U-Bahn, die war relativ voll. Nichts, wo man jetzt als Berliner
sagen würde, holla, das geht gar nicht, sondern war halt voll.
Also keine japanischen Verhältnisse?
Nö, keine zur Tür Reintreter, damit die Leute reinpassen oder so,
aber schon voll. Also das schon.
Und mich hat die U-Bahn im Wesentlichen so ein bisschen noch am meisten an Brüssel erinnert.
Ich weiß nicht genau wieso, aber so einfach so wie sie aussahen,
wie sie klang und wie die Durchsagen waren, das hat mich sehr an Brüssel erinnert.
Sind die da auch auf Chinesisch?
Nee, aber in Brüssel sind sie auch zweisprachig. Also auf Französisch und auf Flämisch.
Ich bin noch nie U-Bahn gefahren.
Die Durchsagen tatsächlich in der U-Bahn auf Englisch und auf Chinesisch sind,
wohingegen sie dann wiederum die Haltestellen nicht unbedingt auf Englisch hingeschrieben haben.
Ich habe mir irgendwann angewöhnt, immer mir so das erste Zeichen zu merken von dem Wort.
Das geht gerade noch so, dass man sich das so merken kann und dann mal so gucken,
ne, könnte das sein? Ne, das erste Zeichen sieht anders aus.
Hattest du denn da keine Traffic-App, die dir irgendwie sagt,
jetzt aussteigen, bla bla bla, so Traffic oder irgendwie sowas?
Nö, ganz normal, Apple Maps. Man hätte mit Apple Maps sogar eine Fahrkarte kaufen können.
Aber hat Apple Maps auch wie hier in Berlin richtig U-Bahn-Tracking?
Ja, ja.
Mit allen Linien und so weiter und wo man aussteigen soll?
Wie gesagt, über Wallet hätte man auch ein Ticket kaufen können.
Das hat aber nicht funktioniert.
Ich meine nur, die App, das macht ja dann, Apple Maps macht das ja auch,
dass sie dir dann auch sagt, wann du aussteigen sollst.
Ja, das stimmt. Stimmt, das hatte ich nicht an.
Guter Punkt, weiß ich nicht.
Also du kannst einfach eine Route machen und dann ich fahre jetzt ÖPNV und dann
sagt er dir halt wirklich jetzt aussteigen, dann hättest du ja nicht so viele Zeichen merken müssen.
Ja, aber bei der U-Bahn ist halt die Lokalisierung nicht so gut,
da musst du dann schon gucken, dass du weißt, wo du bist, also zumindest in
Berlin ist es immer wieder so.
Ja gut, aber zumindest zeigt er dir dann das Zeichen dann auch an und ich weiß
nicht, die Lokalisierung ist in U-Bahnen teilweise gar nicht mal so falsch,
weil die sich dann halt an Wi-Fi,
AP-Adressen und so weiter orientieren.
Die U-Bahn war gut ausgeschildert, fand ich. Also das war jetzt kein Problem irgendwie.
Entschuldigung, nicht Wi-Fi, sondern 5G oder was auch immer.
Auf jeden Fall eine Base Station.
Ja, also das war, man hat sich da zurechtgefunden. Das war jetzt kein größeres Problem.
Na gut.
Und Bahnen sind wir auch gefahren, weil wir nämlich von Shanghai nach Chindao
mit dem Schnellzug gefahren sind.
Die Alternative wäre halt also entweder vier Stunden Schnellzug oder acht Stunden Bus.
und dann haben wir darauf bestanden, dass wir mit dem Schnellzug fahren,
der hat mich so ein bisschen an den TGW erinnert, so ein bisschen enger als ein ICE.
Also ein ICE ist schon geräumiger, fährt auch ein bisschen behäbiger,
wackelt nicht ganz so und ist so ein bisschen vom Luxuriösen her drüber als der TGW, wie ich finde.
Wir haben auch keinen TGW mehr gefahren.
Aber der Zug hat einfach funktioniert. Das Einzige, was wirklich weird ist,
ist, dass du am Bahnhof erst 10 Minuten, bevor der Zug kommt,
überhaupt aufs Gleis gelassen wirst. Also es gibt da so Warte-
Zimmer kann man es nicht nennen, Hallen, Wartehallen, wo du halt auf deinen
Zug wartest und bevor der dann kommt, zehn Minuten bevor der dann kommt,
gehen die Türen auf und dann werden nochmal die Tickets gecheckt,
während du durch die Tür gehst und dann kommst du da rein.
Du kommst übrigens in den Bahnhof auch nur rein, wenn du erstens das Ticket
gezeigt hast und zweitens den Pass und so weiter und das Gepäck wird durchröntgt,
was so richtig bekloppt ist, weil es da Dinge gibt, die du nicht mitnehmen darfst,
aber es gibt ja keine Aufgabe Gepäck, also es ist dann wirklich weg.
Einige Leute haben ihr Rasierschaum oder so abgeben müssen, weil durftest du
halt nicht mit in den Zug nehmen.
Da kommen wir bestimmt auch noch hin.
Ja, naja, auf jeden Fall, auch das hat eigentlich relativ gut geklappt.
Also es gibt keine Wagenstandsanzeige, dafür gibt es auf dem Bahnsteig Markierungen,
wo denn der Wagen mit der und der Nummer anhält bei der und der Klasse Zug und
das hat auch funktioniert.
ich habe nur das bei mir bei der Hinfahrt habe ich irgendwie die Abfahrtszeit
mit dem Sitzplatz verwechselt,
also 8.27 Uhr fuhr der Zug, aber der Sitzplatz wäre in Wagen 5 sonst was gewesen
oder ich glaube der Unterschied war noch größer auf jeden Fall 5 Wagen durch
so einen vollen Zug drängeln ist halt nicht schön so richtig voll,
ja fast ganz voll also aber Aber auch da, der Zug war einfach so auf normalem,
wie soll ich sagen, technischem Landniveau. Also es war jetzt nicht irgendwie,
dass man das Gefühl hat, womit fahren die hier denn.
Es war auch nicht so, dass man dachte, boah, sowas habe ich noch nie gesehen.
Aber es war einfach, es hat funktioniert und es war ein guter Standard. Also das ist wirklich.
Und schnell war der Zug?
Der war schnell, der war, da war irgendwie eine Anzeige, der ist so immer so
um die 180, 190 gefahren. Manchmal ungesetzt.
Das sind ja nicht die schnellen Züge, ne?
Nee, das sind nicht die ganz schnellen Züge, aber das sind.
Überhaupt nicht besonders schnelle Züge, würde ich sagen. 180 ist ja vollkommen normal.
Also in China hast du auch 300 Stunden Gehörer Züge?
Ja, nee, so einen Zug hatten wir nicht. Keine Ahnung, vielleicht wäre der auch teurer gewesen.
Also das war so, nee, also das hat alles irgendwie wirklich einfach funktioniert.
Also ich hatte ja so ein bisschen befürchtet, es wäre so ähnlich wie in Indien,
aber der Unterschied könnte krasser nicht sein.
Also ganz ehrlich, das hat so gut funktioniert, da kann sich manch europäisches
Land echt eine dicke Scheibe von abschneiden.
Ich glaube, technisch kann man sich da mittlerweile sowieso eine ganze Menge abschneiden.
Wir sind auch viel Taxi gefahren, weil es hat halt einfach nichts gekostet.
Also für unsere Verhältnisse nichts.
Generell jetzt das Preisniveau oder jetzt nur speziell auf Taxis?
Kennen ja beides so ein bisschen.
Ich weiß ja nicht, so Restaurants oder so, ich weiß ja nicht,
was du so konsumiert hast da.
Ja, Restaurants, also wir waren nie so richtig fancy im Restaurant,
aber so in so einem Restaurant, so Nudelsuppe und irgendwie zwei,
drei Getränke waren hinterher fünf, sechs Euro in Shanghai, in den anderen Städten
war es ein bisschen billiger.
Also das war relativ günstig.
Relativ günstig. Und beim Taxifahren hatten sie halt so einen Mindesttarif,
der war ungefähr ein Euro.
Es war halt einfach so heiß, irgendwie über 30 Grad, 100 Prozent Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Wir sind irgendwann selbst über die dicke Straße rüber nur noch mit dem Taxi
gefahren, weil es war einfach.
Aber es war auch einfach total simpel, sich ein Taxi zu holen.
Also das war überhaupt kein Problem.
Jetzt mit einer App oder einfach?
Mit einer App. Und zwar, es gibt zwei Apps, die brauchst du unbedingt,
wenn du in China sein willst. Die eine ist WeChat, die kennt man ja.
Und die andere heißt Alipay, von der hat man bestimmt auch schon mal was gehört.
Und beide Apps haben irgendwie so ein Ding durchlaufen, dass sie unglaublich
viele Integrationen haben.
Also mit Alipay kannst du fast überall bezahlen, also so ziemlich überall und mit WeChat meistens.
Also WeChat, WePay. Also in WeChat ist nochmal eine Zahlfunktion dran.
Und Alipay hat eine Integration mit DD Travel.
Das ist so wie Uber.
So nach der Art, ich stehe hier, will ein Taxi und will nach da und da.
Und dann spuckt dir der auch schon aus, wie viel es kostet und dann kommt irgendwie
ein paar Minuten später der Fahrer und fährt dich dahin.
Wie funktioniert das Zahlen damit jetzt konkret? Ist das denn eher so wie bei
Apple Pay oder gibt es physische Terminals, wo du irgendwie was anhältst?
Gut, dass du fragst. Es gibt zwei Varianten. Das eine ist…,
Du zeigst einen QR-Code vor, den die App anzeigt.
Also beide Apps, die unternehmen sich da jetzt nicht so viel.
Und dann kann der Merchant diesen
QR-Code scannen mit seinem Terminal und dadurch die Zahlung auslösen.
Das ist das eine. Und das andere.
Ist… Also der schickt dir über den QR-Code eine Zahlungsaufforderung im Prinzip?
Richtig.
Okay.
Die bestätigst du dann und dann ist fertig. Okay. Oder andersrum,
die haben einen QR-Code, den scannst du und dann tippst du ein,
wie viel du schicken willst und schickst es los.
Okay, klingt easy.
Das ist, man muss halt irgendwie einmal durch dieses,
ich verbinde meine Kreditkarte aus dem Westen mit diesem Systemding durch,
das ist mitunter ein bisschen nervig, weil du dann auch irgendwie quasi deinen
halben Reisepass abtippen musst und noch ein Foto hinschicken und so weiter.
Aber wenn man das einmal gemacht hat, geht das super.
Und dann gibt es noch die Möglichkeit, das hatten wir in dem einen Restaurant auch,
dass sie am Tisch, also ich kannte das von der Ukraine,
da haben sie am Tisch einen QR-Code und dann scannst du mit einem der beiden
Apps diesen QR-Code und dann geht in der App nochmal so eine Art Webview-Integration
auf, wo du dir dann dein Menü zusammenklicken kannst.
und dann sagst du zahlen und dann bezahlst du das, was du haben willst und irgendwann
steht es halt auf dem Tisch.
Das ist irgendwie auch ganz witziges Herangehen.
Das ist auch geil, ja.
Zumindest sind da meistens dann Bilder an dem Essen dran.
Das ist ein bisschen, weil das meiste ist halt nicht übersetzt.
Ich meine, dieser Trend zu diesen Super-Apps, wie man so schön sagt,
Apps, die quasi nicht mehr nur eine Sache machen, sondern eigentlich alles mögliche
einbinden, was ja Elon Musk auch gerne für Twitter gehabt hätte und irgendwie
sind sie davon immer noch weit von entfernt.
Wie auch von all seinen sonstigen ausgerufenen Zielen, zu meiner größten Belustigung.
Lass uns nicht auf diesen Menschen eingehen.
Nein, aber das ist, sagen wir mal, also das, was in Asien gängig ist.
Und WeTrade ist ein Beispiel, Alipay ist ein Beispiel und ich glaube in,
nicht durcheinander kommen.
Ich glaube in Japan ist auch Line in Japan groß.
Also jede Region hat so ein bisschen so seinen Primär-Chat, der so besonders erfolgreich ist.
Das ist eben dann in China vor allem im WeChat.
Und,
Als ich jetzt in Taiwan war, da war es, oh Gott, da war es irgendwas anderes
in Malaysia, das habe ich jetzt vergessen.
Also da sind zum Beispiel auch diese ganzen Transport-Apps, also so wie Uber,
bloß eben nicht Uber, sondern dann ist es dann halt irgendwie zum Beispiel Grab,
wo du dann eben auch Taxis bestellen kannst, Mopeds bestellen kannst,
aber dann auch Restaurant.
und als ich in der Ukraine war, hatte ich auch schon erzählt,
so dieses Bestellen sind halt auch irgendwie so Dinge, die so mit drin sind,
meistens dann wiederum von der kriegst du so ein fertiges Webinterface von der
Bank gestellt als Restaurantbetreiber, also dieses ganze,
wir übernehmen mal diese ganzen Dienste und packen irgendwie alles in ein System
zusammen und eine App ist sozusagen ja eigener Appstore, das ist so ein Trend,
der sich so langsam abzeichnet.
Ich habe auch nicht alles verstanden, was da in Alipay so drin ist,
beziehungsweise in WeChat,
sondern im Prinzip nur die Bezahlfunktion und dieses,
WeChat, das Chat selber auch benutzt, das ist aber,
ehrlich gesagt eher so rudimentär, wenn man so ein Telegram oder so ein Signal kennt,
dann ist das was sehr interessant ist, du kannst was einmal in WeChat drin ist,
kannst du eigentlich nicht wieder rausholen, also du kannst nicht ein Video,
was jemand gepostet hat irgendwie auf deinem Phone laden oder so.
Also das ist ganz merkwürdig. Da, naja.
Aber wisst ihr, wer für Europa uns so eine super App bauen könnte? Victorinox.
Das wäre richtig geil. Die Victorinox App würde ich benutzen.
Noch eine App, die man unbedingt braucht, meiner Meinung nach, ist DeepL.
Also ich habe, Dieb L hat ja jetzt auch so ein, ich kann die Kamera auf irgendwas
richten und bekomme das übersetzt.
Das ist ganz lustig, weil die chinesische Sprache scheint sehr blumig zu sein
und viel Chancen für Interpretation zu bieten und deswegen ist die Übersetzung
auch nicht immer so stabil, sage ich mal.
Mal ist es das, mal ist es das. Ganz lustig anzugucken, aber es ist extrem hilfreich,
weil man mal eben das Phone irgendwo
hinhält und dann bekommt man eine Übersetzung von dem, was da ist.
Genau. E-SIM hatte ich mit Nomad.
Also DeepL scannt auch?
Ja, ja.
Ah, okay, das ist eine neue.
Also die DeepL-App auf dem Phone.
Ja, okay.
Da gibt es einen Kamera-Button, Da drücke ich drauf und dann übersetzt du alles, was du siehst.
Ja gut, das macht ja Google schon relativ lange.
Ja, genau, so macht das DeepL auch. Das hat ganz gut funktioniert.
Irgendwer hat gesagt, man müsse doch unbedingt DeepSeek benutzen.
Das wäre da am allerbesten. Aber das habe ich nicht ausprobiert.
Das kann jetzt nichts zu sagen. Zum Übersetzen? Ja.
Ach echt? Ja gut, ich meine, das können die LLMs ja generell alle ganz gut.
Aber letztlich benutzt ja auch DeepL.
DeepL ist einfach sehr gut im Übersetzen, weil es vor allem Kontextnuancen,
also nicht nur eine Variante anbietet, sondern eben auch im Kontext immer sehr
gut unterwegs ist, sagen wir es mal so.
Also DeepL war immer gut genug und schnell genug, dass ich mich jetzt nicht
nach was anderem umgeguckt habe.
Muss ich jetzt mal einfach zugeben, ich habe jetzt keinen großen Vergleichstest gemacht.
E-SIM habe ich über Nomad gekauft. Das war irgendwie...
wie soll ich sagen, wenig aufregend, hat einfach funktioniert,
fertig. Braucht man jetzt auch nichts zu sagen.
Andere Leute haben Aerolo benutzt oder so. Das ist dann auch, glaube ich, egal.
Nehmt sich auch preislich, glaube ich, nicht viel.
Also Nomad ist schon günstiger. Ich habe ungefähr die Hälfte dessen bezahlt,
was die anderen bezahlt haben.
Aber ob man jetzt 10 Euro für die Daten eines Urlaubs bezahlt oder 20 Euro, das ist dann auch egal.
Also das ist so, was haben wir denn hier, über das Bier habe ich schon gerantet,
Essen muss ich mal sagen, wir haben relativ viele so, wie nannten die das,
immer Mealboxen vom Veranstalter bekommen,
die waren alle doch ziemlich nicht so geil, also da waren so ein paar dabei,
da kann ich jetzt mit Fug und Recht sagen, ich habe den schlechtesten Reis meines
Lebens in China gegessen,
aber gut, das ist halt, naja.
Die haben da wahrscheinlich am Preis gespart, keine Ahnung. Ansonsten war das
Essen okay, aber ich bin jetzt kein großer Fan des chinesischen Essens geworden.
Ja, das ging mir auch so. Zwar nicht in Mainland China, aber halt auch so Taiwan.
Das war alles ganz okay, aber so umgehauen hat mich das jetzt nicht.
Da bin ich dann eher Team Thailand.
Ja, was mich, also uns alle eigentlich schockiert hat, weil man es aus Europa
nicht mehr so üblich, nicht mehr so kennt, ist der Verpackungsmüll.
Das ist wirklich unglaublich. Ich habe irgendwann, also die Chinesen essen ja irgendwie kein Käse.
Aus irgendwelchen Gründen mögen die keinen Käse.
Na, Laktose-Toleranz?
Du, keine Ahnung. Ich habe irgendwann im Supermarkt Käsewürfel gekauft, irgendwas Frischkäse.
Und dann war das so, das war halt alles einmal in Plastik eingeschweißt und
aus diesem Aus, sowieso länglich wie so ein Schokoriegel, wenn man es aufgemacht
hat, war da eine Pappschachtel drin.
In dieser Pappschachtel waren da nochmal einzeln in Staniolfolie eingewickelte
Käsewürfel, so wie man das von Lavaschkiri zum Beispiel kennt oder von diesen
Schmelzkäse-Ecken, so in der Art.
Ja und dann war das Schmelzkäse, der auch noch süß war, also es war,
naja gut, aber auch dieses, verdammt nochmal, warum bleiben die Deckel nicht an den Flaschen dran?
Also ich bitte dich das ist doch.
Nicht so schwer.
Das können wir auch erst seit kurzem da haben sich alle drüber beschwert und.
Ich weiß auch nicht wieso aber plötzlich kaum hat man es nicht mehr ist man
komplett genervt von diesen Deckeln die nicht mehr dranbleiben.
Ja das war an sich eine ganz gute Idee ja.
Ja eigentlich schon.
Manche Sachen muss man auch erst aufgedrückt bekommen bevor man checkt dass
es irgendwie die eigentlich gar nicht so scheiße ist.
Nee, aber insgesamt haben sie ungefähr doppelt so viel Verpackungsmüll um irgendeinem
Produkt rum wie bei uns. Also es ist wirklich absurd.
Irgendwie, ich verstehe es auch nicht.
Ja, das ist generell etwas, wo Asien noch ein bisschen hinterherhängt.
Ich meine, es ist halt, dieser ganze Luxus der modernen Welt ist da immer noch sehr neu.
Das ist alles eine Entwicklung der letzten 30 Jahre.
und da muss noch sehr viel nachgeholt werden in den Köpfen.
Du meinst, Luxus ist, wenn man möglichst viel Unboxing machen kann oder was?
Ja, das... Naja, man weiß doch, was Luxus ist. Man muss...
über Status, über Besitz. Und diese ganze,
ich meine China ist nicht so lange her, da war das Land halt auch noch so von
Hunger geplagt, zumindest in vielen Bereichen und vor allem von sehr starker Armut.
Und jetzt hast du halt einfach so einen, ich weiß nicht, ob man das einen Mittelstand
nennen kann, aber zumindest eine Gesellschaft, die in zunehmendem Maße weniger
mit so einem totalen Mangel zu kämpfen hat.
Und da ist halt einfach dieser ganze Zeigeshow-Status sehr groß.
Ich meine, das war ja, was weiß ich, als hier die Handys kamen,
noch alle mit ihren komischen Handys in irgendwelchen durchsichtigen Taschen
am Gürtel durch die Gegend gerannt.
Damit man es auch sieht.
Damit man es auch sieht, dass man ein Handy hat und so.
Ja, das war schlimm.
Aber das ist halt im Prinzip genau das Gleiche. Und das ist ja auch der Grund,
warum wir immer noch so unter Autos leiden, weil das immer noch so ein krasses Statussymbol ist.
Und die Leute nicht checken, dass das eigentlich wirkliche Statussymbol heutzutage
ein Elektromotorrad ist.
Naja, in China ist, glaube ich, ein Statussymbol tatsächlich ein europäisches
oder am besten deutsches Auto.
Immer noch?
Ja, ja. Egal, ob das dann irgendwie nicht mit Strom fährt oder so oder andere größere Nachteile hat.
Aber es scheint doch, also es gibt da wirklich Leute, die mit ganz offensichtlicher
Zufriedenheit und zur Schaustellung irgendwie den BMW oder den Mercer vorfahren.
Ich verstehe es nicht, aber gut, ich muss das vielleicht auch nicht verstehen.
Als letztes vielleicht noch Shanghai. Wir waren da abends dort und da gibt es ja diese,
also da fließt ja so ein Fluss durch, keine Ahnung wie der jetzt heißt und auf
der anderen Seite von dem Fluss, wo man als Tourist üblicherweise ist,
stehen relativ viele Hochhäuser und die sind alle absurd beleuchtet.
Also absurd beleuchtet im Sinne von….
Sehr viel schlechter Geschmack.
Ich sag mal so, du kennst dich ja so ein bisschen aus, wie man Gebäude beleuchtet.
Ich will nicht über Geschmack streiten, es ist nur einfach, also es ist vor
allen Dingen auch viel hilft viel und vor allen Dingen viel Animation hilft viel.
Es bewegt sich und tut und macht und so weiter.
Und das Schlimme ist, aus ganz China kommt der Tourist an und will das sehen.
Das heißt, da wo du tagsüber noch relativ normal rumlaufen kannst,
ja gut, da sind Leute, aber ist okay, ist es hinterher verstopft,
als wäre da ein Oktoberfest oder so am Start.
Und alle glotzen sie da auf dieses Wasser rüber auf die andere Seite,
wo die Hochhäuser blinken.
Das ist überall, das ist in Hongkong auch so, Dubai,
also Dubai hat das jetzt nicht so auf der kompletten Skyline,
aber die haben das halt schon auch da etwas konzentrierter und das ist halt
immer noch alles irgendwie neu und so während wir so völlig schon so auf dem,
können wir mal wieder das mit der Natur probieren,
Film langsam geraten, in Teilen der Gesellschaft zumindest, ja.
Dunkelpark oder Sternenpark.
Ja, Sternenpark und irgendwie, also überhaupt so und auch diese permanente Reizüberflutung.
Und das ist halt einfach, glaube ich, etwas, was da einfach immer noch einen
sehr hohen Stellenwert hat.
Ich meine, die übertreiben es ja auch gleich richtig. Hast du auch mal so eine
Drohnenlichtshow gesehen?
Nee, das hatten sie da nicht. Okay, aber du weißt, was ich meine.
Ich habe Videos gesehen davon, das ist, ja klar.
Aber ja, man hat auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass die Firmen,
die da ihr Hochhaus haben, das natürlich auch als komplettes Statussymbol sehen
und die sich versuchen gegenseitig zu übertrumpfen. Also das ist ganz offensichtlich.
Aber ja, also kann man mal hinfahren und sich das angucken. Also finde ich jetzt nicht verkehrt.
Ja, das war es im Wesentlichen.
Wie lange warst du da?
Das waren elf Tage.
Vielleicht noch eine Kleinigkeit. Wir haben da ja in Konzertsaalen gesungen
und gerade der Konzertsaal in Chindao, der war schon richtig gut.
Also jetzt keine Philharmonie, aber auch nicht deutlich drunter.
Leider war das kein Philharmonie-Publikum. Also das habe ich noch nicht erlebt,
dass die Leute ihre Handys nicht ausmachen.
Okay, muss man vielleicht nicht. Aber dass sie sie auch nicht leise machen und
dann wirklich mit hoher Lautstärke das Gepiepse anfängt, immer wenn irgendwo
eine Message reinkommt oder so oder die Leute angerufen werden und auch noch
rangehen und telefonieren.
Über Husten will ich gar nicht reden. Also das fand ich schon sehr, sehr weird.
Ich habe das zweite Konzert ja nicht mitgesungen, weil Stimme nicht wollte.
Und dann saß ich neben einem, der hat tatsächlich während das Konzert lief,
irgendwelche News geguckt.
Der hatte dann so Stöpsel im Ohr und es hat jetzt, gut, hat man nichts gehört,
aber trotzdem war der da irgendwie bei seinen, ich glaube Börsen-News oder so
waren das, keine Ahnung. Also es war ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Ja, also ich will jetzt ohne eigene konkrete Erfahrungen eigentlich gar nicht
so viel drüber sagen, aber die Chinesen, die mainland Chinesen haben ja so im
Rest Asiens eigentlich einen relativ schlechten Ruf, was so ihre Manieren betrifft.
Da ist viel Lärm und laut sein und auf den Boden spucken und rumrotzen und so
weiter, das scheint da sehr verbreitet zu sein.
Ich sag mal so, wenn man als Deutscher das Gefühl hat, Dass man mit der Art,
wie man so normalerweise durchs Leben geht, also innerhalb von einem halben Tag das Gefühl hat,
muss ich mich jetzt nicht großartig
anstrengen, ich werde hier nicht anecken, dann sagt das schon was.
Also ich glaube, dass es so Länder gibt, wo man so versucht,
lieber nicht Fauxpas machen und lieber nicht hier und nochmal zweimal bitte
und danke sagen und so, damit man jetzt nicht der Depp aus dem Westen ist,
aber das Gefühl hast du in China gar nicht.
Da kannst du dich sozusagen so schlecht benehmen, wie du willst.
Du hast immer noch gute Manieren, willst du sagen.
Also wenn wir auf den Klischees rumhacken würden, dann würde ich jetzt sagen,
gut, Amerikaner fallen vielleicht trotzdem noch auf.
Aber so als Deutsche, jetzt mal abgesehen vom Aussehen her, ich hatte nicht
das Gefühl, dass wir uns da jetzt schlecht benommen hätten.
Wir haben uns relativ normal benommen. Das wollen wir ja auch hoffen.
Rudi, dass du dich da ordentlich benommen hast.
Ich benehme mich ja sowieso meistens ordentlich.
Streistens.
Es gibt Ausnahmen, aber darüber reden wir heute nicht.
Gut, das war der Bericht aus China. Ja. Okay.
Hast du noch Fragen? Luca, warst du mal in China?
Nee, ich war noch nie in China. Ich war generell noch nie in Asien tatsächlich.
Würde ich gerne auch irgendwann mal nachholen.
Also im Großen und Ganzen war es nicht, deutlich weniger schwierig,
als ich gedacht hätte, dass das ist.
Auch wenn der Veranstalter so ein bisschen weird war und uns irgendwie,
ich glaube drei Wochen oder vier Wochen vorher dann eröffnete,
wir bräuchten dann doch noch ein Arbeitsvisum, weil dieser Auftritt ja doch
irgendwie Arbeit darstellt.
Das haben dann irgendwie die meisten vom Chor auch noch irgendwie hingekriegt.
aber im Großen und Ganzen war das jetzt irgendwie völlig unklar also die Vorstellung
jetzt nach Amerika zu fahren würde mir deutlich mehr Bedenken,
machen als jetzt nochmal nach China zu fahren mir.
Auch gut Luca und ich, wir waren ja auch unterwegs, wir haben es ja hier auch
schon mal angekündigt und haben einen Ausflug nach Schweden gemacht.
Und auch wenn ich Schweden schon mal betreten habe in meinem Leben,
ich war mal einen Tag in Malmö.
Also bis jetzt vorletzten Woche.
Ja gut, also ein Tag in Malmö ist auch Schweden irgendwie.
Aber ist Schweden, aber ich habe halt relativ wenig Schweden mitgenommen und
das würde ich auch ehrlich gesagt, das gilt im Prinzip jetzt auch für diese Reise.
Ich bin bloß mal ein bisschen weiter gekommen.
Wir waren ja auf dem Weg zu einer Elixier-Konferenz und ja, die war in Warberg.
Warberg.
Warberg. Das ist, glaube ich, die korrekte Aussprache.
Das geben wir nochmal.
Oder zumindest bin ich näher...
Ist da irgendwo den Namen in den Notes drin?
Da schreibt sie einfach V-A-R-Berg.
Ja, G wird als J gesprochen.
Genau. Und das R soll wohl gerollt werden und ja.
Ja, das ist so ein kleiner Ort, kurz vor Göteborg und ganz nett so gelegen am Wasser.
Oder Götebori wieder.
Ja, und ich weiß gar nicht, also was mir als erstes aufgefallen ist,
dass ich so überhaupt keinerlei Anpassungsprobleme hatte an Schweden.
also das klingt jetzt ein bisschen blöd aber es ist so es war so Deutschland light.
In welcher Hinsicht?
Na, eigentlich in jeder Hinsicht, weil es einfach, die Dinge sind da einfach
nicht so sehr viel anders.
Also du kommst ins Supermarkt und irgendwie, okay, es gibt ein bisschen mehr Schöttbola.
Und ein bisschen weniger Bier.
Genau, man kann da keinen Alkohol kaufen über, was war die Grenze nochmal?
3,5 glaube ich. Genau, 3,5 Prozent Alkoholgehalt.
Stärkeres gibt es dann nur bei der zentralen Abgabestelle.
Genau, machen es halt wie, glaube ich, alle in Skandinavien und Kanada,
dass sie sozusagen den harten Alk halt quasi vom Staat verkaufen lassen.
Ja, als ich in Schweden war, das ist auch schon über zehn Jahre her,
da sind wir mit dem Auto und der Fähre gefahren und da war direkt vor uns ein
Kombi von vier Schweden.
Der war hinten bis unter den Dachhimmel mit Bierdosen voll.
Und kaum kam dieses Auto auf der Fähre zum Stehen, fielen drei komplett besoffene
Schweden und einige leere Paletten Bier aus diesem Auto raus.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob die das da so richtig machen.
Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte ist,
wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel in Großbritannien in einen Supermarkt gehst,
da hast du es wirklich mit einer überwältigenden Zahl von Produkten zu tun,
wo du erstmal überhaupt nicht weißt, was ist das und vor allem hast du es mit
so einigen Produkten nicht zu tun, die du jetzt vielleicht gerade mal so suchst,
aber die es halt so in dieser Kategorisierung
nicht gibt oder zumindest nicht so ohne weiteres zu finden sind.
Oder ganz anders schmecken.
Ja, naja gut, UK ist ein schlechtes Beispiel, weil die jetzt nicht mehr in der EU sind.
Ja, aber es ist auch mit anderen Ländern so. Du hast immer andere Schwerpunkte.
Ich sage jetzt nicht, wenn du jetzt in die Niederlande fährst,
dann ist ja auch nicht gleich die Welt auf den Kopf gestellt,
aber ich fand es einfach auffällig, wie nah Schweden jetzt an Deutschland dran
war, was diesen Aspekt betrifft.
Und auch ansonsten sieht es alles eigentlich sehr kontinental-europäisch aus.
Was mich verwundert hat, ist, dass man irgendwie überall eine relativ gute Pizza bekommt.
Als hätten sie es erfunden. Also auch in dem kleinsten Dorf gibt es irgendwie
noch den Pizzamann, der irgendwie ordentliche Pizza aus dem Ofen holt.
Da sagst du was Interessantes.
Im Warbeck hatten wir auch sehr gute Pizza.
Allerdings, wir hatten ja ausgesprochen gute Pizza.
Ich kann da jetzt keinen Trend draus ablesen und so. Was war denn dein erster Eindruck, Luca?
Ja, ist schön gewesen in Warbeck, ist ja eine kleine Stadt, irgendwie so 30.000
Einwohner, wenn ich das recht erinnere.
Man merkt, dass das ein bisschen eine wohlhabendere Stadt ist,
das merkt man, glaube ich.
relativ viele super teure Camper, die da am Hafen stehen das war schon auffällig,
also ich glaube da machen die etwas
gut betuchteren Schweden gerne selber Urlaub, war so mein Eindruck ja,
das Essen, Pizza habe ich ja schon erwähnt, war super, gleich am ersten Abend
einfach mal auf gut Glück in den Pizzaladen gegangen und der war gut,
ja, was gibt es noch zu sagen über Warbeck?
Mir ging es jetzt erstmal gar nicht so sehr um Warbeck, sondern um.
In Schweden.
Ja, oder was auch bei dir noch so aufgefallen ist.
Ja, also ich war ja tatsächlich schon ein paar Mal in Schweden.
Davor war ich zuletzt allerdings eher an der Ostküste und mehr so im ländlichen
Bereich, wo ich da mit Freunden wandern war.
Das war eine komplett andere Experience, würde ich sagen.
Verstehe.
Okay. Es war ganz anders.
Für dich war das alles nicht so neu?
Nö. Aber ich gebe dir recht, dass irgendwie diese Deutschlandkompatibilität
irgendwie schon da ist. Gerade im Supermarkt hat man es gemerkt, ja.
Ja, und dann waren wir ja auf Konferenz, wie angekündigt. Und das war wirklich toll.
Also das war wirklich eine sehr gute Idee, da hinzufahren, weil das so eine
Community, 200 Leute waren das ungefähr, oder? Hast du mal eine Zeit gehört?
Ja, ich glaube schon. Ja, ungefähr so oder wahrscheinlich unter 200, denke ich.
Genau, und das fand so in so einem schicken Theater in der Stadt, mitten in der City,
eine Altstadt da statt und war einfach hervorragend organisiert und war vor
allem so erfreulich unkommerziell.
Also das hat man irgendwie gemerkt, weil gerade so in diesen,
Programmiersprachen, Konferenzen, so Developer-Kram, ich weiß nicht,
ob du an sowas mal teilgenommen hast, Roddy, aber da hast du,
wenig überraschend, so einen totalen Business-Fokus.
Sponsoren, Vorträge und alles ist auch so ein bisschen etwas langweilig strukturiert
in meinen Augen und dann auch so etwas lieblos in irgendwelche Hotels reingesetzt
und da muss man sich dann irgendwie mit abfinden.
Hängt von der Konferenz ab, finde ich. Also ich kenne Konferenzen durchaus,
die auch sehr liebevoll gemacht sind oder waren, die leider alle nicht mehr existieren.
Also einmal die NSConf in England, die so einen Typ gemacht hat,
der einfach dafür gelebt hat, eine gute Konferenz zu machen.
NSConf ist wahrscheinlich Open-Spring.
Schwieriger Name in Deutschland.
Ja, aber es war Next Step. Also es war quasi, noch bevor es das iPhone gab,
war das halt die quasi Insider-Konferenz für alle Leute, die für macOS Software gemacht haben.
Und dann in Berlin gab es lange die UI-Conf, die nach dem Erscheinen des iPhones
dann halt auch sehr starken Fokus auf iOS und so weiter hatte und die aber auch
einen gewissen Community-Fokus hatte.
Also wir hatten von der Firma da auch gesponsert und hatten dann auch einen
Stand, um irgendwie Leute halt dazu zu bringen, sich bei uns zu bewerben,
was natürlich einen gewissen Businessfokus hat, aber es war kein übermäßig super krass.
Das gab es da auch auf jeden Fall.
Also ich fand, ich habe vor ein paar Jahren,
fünf Jahren oder so, war ich mal auf einer Dreutkonf und fand die doch eher so,
wie du das jetzt beschrieben hast, von wegen sehr, sehr businessy und irgendwie
alle laufen rum und versuchen irgendwie irgendwelches Zeug zu verkaufen.
Weiß ich nicht.
Gut, Gurtmeier geht zurück auf einen alten Namen der Stadt Warberg und offensichtlich,
muss das irgendwie sowas wie Ziegensumpf oder so geheißen haben,
weil daraus hat sich sozusagen dieser Name abgeleitet.
Der Konferenz.
Der Konferenz, genau. Wörtlich übersetzt ist es ein Ziegensumpf.
Und deswegen war so die Ziege auch so ein bisschen das das Element,
das wiederkehrende Element, was dann auch in allen Vorträgen oder in vielen
Vorträgen zumindest aufgegriffen wurde und ja, viel Ziegen auf jeden Fall,
was ja auch ganz lustig ist, weil Goat ist ja.
Greatest of all time.
Genau, ist ja ohnehin irgendwie ein tolles Wort in der Hinsicht,
von daher hat es alles ganz gut.
Aber Berlin heißt auch Sumpf, also so ist es ja nun nicht.
Ja, irgendwann war alles mal Sumpf, meistens.
Wenn es kein Berg war, ja.
Wenn es kein Berg war, war es Sumpf. Ja, Warberg ist sozusagen Sumpf und Berg in einem.
Uh, der Sumpfberg.
Der Sumpfberg.
Ja, gut, jetzt war das natürlich alles sehr programmiersprachenspezifisch,
von daher tut es jetzt, glaube ich, es ist, glaube ich, relativ müßig,
da jetzt auf einzelne Vorträge einzugehen. Es gab aber ein paar Ausnahmen.
Und die Veranstaltung war tatsächlich eigentlich zwei Veranstaltungen in einem.
Der erste Tag war nämlich die NERVS-Conf, das ist sozusagen ein bisschen mehr
die IoT-orientierte Teil gewesen.
Und dann der zweite Teil, also der zweite und der dritte Tag,
das war dann die eigentliche Elixier-Konferenz.
Ja, und es fing ja auch irre an, ne, Luca?
Ja, es fing an mit einem super coolen Projekt von, ich glaube drei Belgiern.
Die haben ein, was für eine Karre haben die genommen?
Polo.
Polo, richtig, ein VW Polo haben sie genommen und den elektrifiziert.
Und nicht nur elektrifiziert, sondern auch fernsteuerbar gemacht.
Und das haben sie in einer super coolen Präsentation gezeigt.
Das war natürlich in der Präsentation jetzt sehr elixierlastig.
mit Elixir haben sie halt so wie sie das nannten, das Car Management System,
nee Vehicle Management System gebaut, was die ganzen Komponenten aus dem Auto
anspricht über CAN-Bus im Prinzip, also jede einzelne Komponente wie,
die Lenk Achse, wie nennt sich das auf Deutsch Steering Column,
die Handbremse, alles was halt irgendwie mit dem Auto,
interagiert schickt was auf diesen Bus Ja, das ist ein großes Problem.
Aber das ist am Rande.
Naja klar, das ist ein Problem, aber sie haben im Prinzip das komplette Auto reingeniert.
Das ist die eigentliche Leistung dabei. Sie haben sozusagen alle Protokolle
aller Komponenten reingeniert,
also gelesen, interpretiert, dokumentiert und dann entsprechende Steuerung dafür
gecodet, bis irgendwann das ganze Fahrzeug komplett mit Elixier steuerbar war.
Und dann haben sie auch so ein Infotainment-System, wo du dann sehen kannst,
was der Status ist vom Auto, welche Tür ist gerade offen, wie ist der Status von der Gangschaltung.
Ich glaube, die Gangschaltung haben sie auf dieses Infotainment-System gelegt.
Also es ist natürlich keine normale Gangschaltung wie beim Verbrenner,
sondern Park Neutral Reverse Drive. Das hatten sie da drin.
In dem Video saß, aber nach einem H-Pattern-Shifter aus, also so einer normalen Hahergangsschaltung.
Es war eigentlich ein normaler Verbrenner mit normaler Schaltung.
Und sie haben ein Elektroauto draus gemacht.
Na gut, vielleicht haben sie das Getriebe drin gelassen.
Das Getriebe haben sie drin gelassen. Die haben da sogar noch einen eigenen
Getriebeadapter gedruckt.
Dank des Adapters.
Genau, also mit so 3D-Druck und so weiter gearbeitet. Also super aufwendig.
Ich hoffe schwer, die werden sich bewerben. Ich hoffe schwer,
dass die auf den Kongress kommen. Das ist wirklich cool, weil das Auto fährt halt auch alleine.
Also es ist sozusagen fernsteuerbar.
Die stehen dann da mit dem D-Controller und fahren dieses Auto über den Parkplatz.
Das war schon alles ziemlich cool.
Kleiner Funfact zu Canbus. Cargolifter, wo ich ja mal gearbeitet habe,
Die haben damals auch versucht,
in ihrem Cargolifter Canbus zu benutzen und sind dann auf den Trichter gekommen,
dass die Buslegge beim Canbus irgendwie kürzer ist als das, was der Cargolifter
lang ist und dass das irgendwie alles nichts wird mit dem Canbus.
Ich weiß nicht, wie sie geplant hatten, diese Probleme in den Griff zu kriegen,
aber Canbus war auf jeden Fall draußen.
Ja, aber es ist halt die Realität der Kanbus. Das muss auf jeden Fall gemacht
werden und ich fand das einfach super bemerkenswert, wie die das geschafft haben, das alles zu machen.
Jetzt ist ja, sagen wir mal, für Elixier-Insider und Erlang-Menschen ist es
ja quasi keine Neuigkeit,
dass man mit der Sprache hervorragend so Binär-Protokolle machen, implementieren kann.
weil dir da einfach der Programmierstyle entsprechend entgegenkommt.
Weil du ja, da reden wir nachher nochmal drüber, so ein deklaratives Konzept
hast, wo du einfach sagst, naja, wenn dieses Bitpattern jetzt hier irgendwie
aufschlägt, dann machst du mal den Code.
Und wenn dieses Bitpattern aufschlägt, dann machst du mal den Code.
Und alles, was quasi in dieses Pattern nicht reinpasst, führt gar nicht erst
zu Problemen, sondern das wird dann einfach weggecrasht und kann dann Schritt
für Schritt implementiert werden.
aber wenn dir dann irgendwelche Protokollfehler um die Ohren fliegen,
dann legt es halt nicht gleich deine Software lahm.
Ja, naja, obwohl CANBUS, ich glaube aus dem OCD, OBDCD oder wie das Ding heißt,
dieser Stecker, OBDC, wie auch immer, da ist ja im Prinzip auch der CANBUS drauf.
Also diese ganzen Protokolle von den ganzen Teilen sind ja mehr oder weniger bekannt.
Also die findest du, da musst du nicht so fürchterlich viel reverse-engineeren.
Na, du musst ja alles richtig steuern.
Ja gut, aber es ist ja ein Bus. Also du kannst ja sehen, wie ein Teil zum anderen
spricht, um es richtig zu steuern.
Ja genau, das haben sie ja auch gemacht.
Das haben sie so gemacht.
Genau, das war ja die eigentliche Leistung und das musst du dann aber auch erstmal
tun und verstehen, damit das Auto dann auch gefahren werden kann.
Weil da gehört natürlich einiges dazu. Auf jeden Fall ist das alles komplett
Open Source, das Projekt und wirklich sehr geil. und es war natürlich jetzt
kein zugelassenes Fahrzeug, aber es fuhr.
Also es war auf jeden Fall sehr beeindruckend. Und eine zweite Sache,
die auch sehr beeindruckend war,
die auch, sagen wir mal, erst mal so am Rande was mit Elixir zu tun hatte und
dafür aber an unsere letzte Sendung hier anknüpft, als wir uns nebenbei über so Computer,
wie haben wir es genannt, so Generated Music unterhalten haben.
also Software Defined, Software Generated Music ähm,
Das kam auch schon in den Kommentaren, wir hatten ja, glaube ich,
diesen Clip gehabt und das basierte dann letzten Endes auf diesem Strudel-System.
Das war, glaube ich, Tidal Cycles, wenn ich mich nicht irre.
Und Strudel ist, basiert aber auf Tidal Cycles.
Nee, ich glaube, Huckel hatte Strudel gesagt.
Ja, ich meine.
Weil Tidal Cycles habe ich noch nie gehört. Es muss Strudel gewesen sein.
Tidal Cycles war, glaube ich, das andere, ich krieg's jetzt nicht mehr ganz zusammen.
Das ist das Ding in Haskell.
Ja, achso, genau. Na, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall, was auf der Konferenz
war, war halt der Sam Aaron und das ist der Autor von Sonic Pi.
Und Sonic Pi geht so in so eine ähnliche Richtung und der hat das halt live
on stage performt und das war schwer beeindruckend.
Du hast ja Sonic Pi noch ein bisschen angeschaut, Luca, ne?
Genau, ich hab damit ein bisschen rumgespielt. Also Music Live Coding.
nennt sich dieses Genre der Programmierung quasi oder der Musik.
Man kann damit relativ cool Sachen machen, wenn man sich damit auskennt.
Es ist schwierig, da reinzukommen, glaube ich. Oder fand ich jetzt zumindest.
Dieses Strudel, falls sich das mal jemand angeschaut hatte nach der letzten
Sendung, das ist, glaube ich, JavaScript-basiert alles.
man schreibt sich so einzelne man kann einzelne Patterns definieren von Noten
dann sagen, ja das spiel jetzt bitte mit diesem Instrument ab,
dann die ganzen Parameter für die Synthesizer kannst du einstellen und das chained
man alles so als Funktionsaufruf,
nacheinander weg und hat dann quasi ein vielleicht ein Element des Tracks geschrieben,
Bei Sonic Pi läuft das ein bisschen anders. Sonic Pi, das benutzt Ruby übrigens,
also nicht jetzt Elixir.
Das ist eher ein prozeduraler Approach.
Also da kann man sich auch eine, hat er auch demonstriert in seinem Talk,
eine Endlosschleife schreiben und dann war es das mit der Musik.
Kommt nichts mehr, es blockt dann für immer den Thread.
Ja, es ist halt für so Sample-Sachen ganz gut geeignet.
Samples choppen, lustig abspielen mit Randomness.
Er hat viel Randomness, meine ich, erwähnt auch in seinem Talk,
dass du halt, du willst irgendwie Randomness haben in deinem Track.
Das soll sich so ein bisschen unberechenbar verhalten, aber du möchtest auch,
dass es sich irgendwann wiederholt.
Also nicht komplett random. Wenn das komplett random ist, dann ist es halt meistens
keine interessante Musik mehr.
Darauf war viel eingegangen. Das habe ich zum Beispiel bei Strudel jetzt vermisst.
So diese coolen Randomness-Features, die er da eingebaut hat.
kann ich nur jedem empfehlen, der irgendwie ein bisschen sich für Musik interessiert
einfach mal runterladen.
Damit rumspielen Ja, ich fand das auch sehr beeindruckend weil der Typ einfach,
wir haben uns auch auf der Konferenz ein bisschen mit ihm unterhalten,
er saß dann irgendwie bei uns am Tisch und ist einfach eine coole Sau der Typ,
muss man weiß nicht anders sagen also wirklich völlig motiviert und,
benutzt das halt auch, um Kindern dann Musik beizubringen und so.
Und so ist das Tool auch entstanden, glaube ich, so als Lernwerkzeug.
Und dafür taugt es. Also du hast sozusagen Programmieren und Musik in einem.
Du kannst es aber beides sozusagen, also du kannst sowohl über das Programmieren
an die Musik kommen, als auch über die Musik ans Programmieren.
Je nachdem, wie man das so sehen möchte.
Ja, das war auf jeden Fall eine sehr coole Einrahmung.
Also mehrere Male auf der Konferenz, auch mit dem Talk und mit einer Performance
noch am Schluss auch nochmal dabei und das hat auch dem Ganzen dann auch nochmal
sehr coolen Vibe gegeben.
Und er hatte ja auch noch einen Appell an die Leute, den ich auch ganz gut fand,
mehr nicht Business-Sachen coden, einfach mal Sachen programmieren,
die Spaß machen, die unsinnig sind.
Ja, da hat er natürlich recht.
Auf jeden Fall hat er da recht.
Ja, und dann gab es noch was Nettes. Und zwar, jetzt wollen wir,
glaube ich, ein bisschen ausholen.
Also, diese Erlangen-Elixier-Welt, die ist ja im gesamten Programmieruniversum eine Nische.
Etwas überschaubar, ja.
Also wie das immer so ist mit diesen Nischen, es gibt da natürlich auch Bereiche,
wo es halt dominiert. Nur sieht das nicht unbedingt jetzt jeder.
Erlang ist halt traditionell einfach im Telekom-Bereich sehr stark.
Du kannst davon ausgehen, dass sehr viele deiner Telefongespräche,
die du in deinem Leben geführt hast, hinter den Kulissen durch Erlang-Code letztlich
zustande gekommen sind.
Ja, einerseits ja. Andererseits, wenn ich mir angucke,
wie viele Leute Node.js inzwischen machen und wenn irgendwo wieder irgendjemand
Scheiß eingebaut hat in irgendeiner sonstigen Library und die ganze JavaScript-Welt
wieder amok läuft, die Welt geht unter,
da ist viel zu viel von dem Kram da draußen.
Genau, deswegen braucht man ja ordentliche Softwarebasis und da ist halt dann
einfach mal Erlang ein anderer Ansatz, hatte ich ja vor einiger Zeit hier schon mal auch hergeleitet,
dass ich denke, dass sich hier so ein Raum in der Softwarewelt auftut,
der einfach nach etwas anderen Prinzipien und Motivationen arbeitet,
als dass man so in anderen Bereichen hat.
und das merkt man auch an dieser Community extrem also die Zahl von Leuten die da so,
Checkungen haben und die irgendwie so auch so einen bestimmten Style haben und
auch einfach keinen Dreck mehr sehen wollen, der ist extrem hoch.
Das ist auch so ein Fluchtraum in gewisser Hinsicht für viele Leute.
Also das kam auch in vielen Talks, kam das immer wieder entweder,
im Mittelpunkt oder nebenbei so zu sprechen, dass man am Ende aus gutem Grund
gelandet ist, da gelandet ist, wo wir jetzt alle da waren.
Das Problem ist glaube ich an der Stelle, da kommt man erst hin,
wenn man erst mal vorher ein bisschen Bullshit gesehen hat.
Genau, das denke ich auch. Also das ist auf jeden Fall so eine Asylzone.
Also wenn du so aus dem Java-Kampfgebiet kommst, dann willst du halt irgendwann
einfach mal deinen Frieden finden
und das ist dann halt definitiv so ein Bereich, wo du das machen kannst.
So, aber ich wollte ja auf diese Nischen eigentlich hinaus und der Telekom-Bereich
ist halt eine dieser Nischen mit dem Aufkommen von Elixir und dem Phoenix-Framework
ist definitiv Web-Server, die,
schlank laufen und sehr zuverlässig sind.
Eine sehr große weitere Nische und mittlerweile macht ja diese ganze Elixir-Phoenix-Welt,
würde ich sagen, gefühlt 95% der Aktivität in dieser Szene aus.
Weil das halt einfach noch mal viel größer ist als der ganze Telekom-Bereich.
Da draußen läuft halt extrem viel auf Java VM und ich sag mal Java VM und seine
Garbage Collection, das ist wie Fusion Power.
Die nächste Garbage-Collection ist die,
die dann auch wirklich alles richten wird und dann wird es auch wirklich richtig
gut performen und wenig Speicher brauchen und irgendwie sind diese Versprechen
nach wie vor nicht erfüllt worden und wenn du irgendwas mit Java brauchst,
dann kannst du auch irgendwie gleich den 100er-Pack-RAM-Riegel einpacken,
weil es einfach unglaublich viel Speicher verbraucht.
Ja, genau. In anderen Sprachen haben so alle ihre Probleme.
Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich mehr so drauf, warum eigentlich,
also was entwickelt sich eigentlich jetzt in dieser Welt.
Und wie gesagt, Telekommunikation war stark, Web-Server,
also Web-Backend und Web in welcher Ausprägung auch immer, ob es jetzt Webseiten
sind oder Automatisierungs-Backends, Sachen, die überhaupt gar keine Webseiten
machen, sondern nur API-Calls machen, was es auch immer ist.
Wenn du mit dem Internet, HTTP oder auch mit irgendwelchen anderen Protokollen
zu Werke bist und du brauchst da einfach stabile Software,
die sehr gut mit sehr viel kleinteiligen Nachrichten klarkommt oder eben auch
so Binärprotokollen, wie wir das schon hatten.
Das ist definitiv so ein Bereich, wo super viel passiert und ein weiterer Bereich,
wo eben Elixir sich jetzt breit macht, ist dieser IoT-Bereich.
Und zwar halt eher so in dieser Kategorie Raspberry Pi, diese günstigen Devices,
die halt nur für irgendwie 100 Euro kriegst du eine passable Computing-Plattform
und du hast halt dann irgendwelche, was weiß ich,
Anzeigen, Sensoren, Messgeräte,
Aktuatoren, Überwachungskameras und so weiter.
und du hast halt potenziell sehr viele davon.
Ich glaube, dieser Frank Hanslis hat ja gesagt, der an diesem,
komme ich jetzt gleich drauf, auf dieses Nerv-System mitarbeitet,
der ist in einer Smart-Home-Firma unterwegs und haben die halt aber tausende
so Devices in so Apartments, die so vermietet werden.
Oder also, was weiß ich, vom Türeingangssystem, Überwachungskameras,
Temperatur, Klima, Management, Lichtsteuerung und so weiter.
Also quasi so richtig Smart Home bis zum Anschlag.
Aber tausende von Wohnungen mit einer Vielzahl von diesen Steuergeräten am Start
haben und das halt dann maintainen müssen.
Also Firmware, die stabil läuft, immer zuverlässig und so weiter funktioniert.
und genau, das ist dieses NERVs-Projekt, also so wie Phoenix quasi die Plattformen
fürs Web super interessant gemacht hat,
ist für diesen IoT-Bereich halt dieses NERVs-Projekt und NERVs ist im Prinzip
was relativ Einfaches, das ist eigentlich,
Kann man so sagen. Das ist eigentlich im Wesentlichen so ein Packaging-System.
Das heißt, du kannst auf deinem Desktop-Computer sagen, ja hier,
ich hätte jetzt hier gerne mal die Software auf diesem Raspberry Pi am Laufen.
Hier ist so die Software.
Man konfiguriert ein paar Sachen, sagt, was die Target-Plattform ist,
compilt das alles durch und am Ende hast du ein fertiges Image.
Das heißt, der baut dir nicht nur das Programm, sondern der baut dir im Prinzip
die komplette Runtime, die dann da läuft und du brennst dieses Image direkt
auf eine SD-Karte, steckst es in deinen Raspberry Pi, schaltest den ein und die Sache läuft.
Und das ist eigentlich ziemlich sexy, weil das eben alles so aus einem Guss
ist und du nicht diesen Distributions- oder überhaupt erstmal diesen Initialisierungsaufwand
hast, die Kisten überhaupt erstmal mit irgendwas an Start zu bringen.
Wobei ich finde ja immer noch, für Raspberry Pi gibt es nach wie vor keine gute
Entwicklungsumgebung.
Was ich gerne hätte, wäre so ein System, was so ähnlich wie Docker was zusammenbastelt
und das dann entweder auf eine VM, eine Raspberry Pi VM schiebt,
damit man es debuggen kann oder auf eine SD-Karte, damit man direkt vom Raspberry Pi booten kann.
Aber irgendwie hat sich niemand die Mühe gemacht, sowas mal ein ordentlich zu bauen.
Also ich würde sagen, Nerves macht sowas.
Da fällt ein Image raus, da ist so ein minimales Bildroot-basiertes Linux drauf.
Es bootet direkt in Erlang-VM mit Elixir.
Kannst du das auch direkt in der VM laufen lassen?
Warum?
Weil ich mich nicht mit so langsam bootenden Pies rumärgern will.
Bei Raspberry Pi habe ich nicht die Geduld. Das ist mir einfach alles zu langsam.
Was, die stört jetzt die Hardware?
Ja.
Du kannst natürlich auch irgendwas anderes targeten.
So ein Mac ist doch ein schneller Arm drin.
Ja, aber da brauchst du ja den Nervs nicht.
Du kannst sogar den Host targeten. Also wenn du so ein Nervs-Projekt erstellst,
dann hast du so verschiedene Targets, wie Tim schon meinte.
Es gibt da Raspberry Pi 4, 3, whatever.
Und es gibt auch immer das Host-Target. Also dann brauchst du dir halt die Software,
die du da schreibst, auf deinem Host einfach laufen lassen.
Auf VMs auch, ich weiß nicht, ob es da jetzt, das war was, was bei der Konferenz angesprochen wurde,
da ging es um ein Target, was glaube ich einen speziellen Hypervisor targetet,
weiß ich nicht mehr genau, aber ist möglich.
Naja, aber es wäre halt schön, einfach das, was auf der SD-Karte ist,
einfach auch lokal laufen zu lassen, bevor ich dann die SD-Karte in den Pi schiebe.
Meist du dasselbe Binary?
Dasselbe Binary.
Ja, dann brauchst du ja dann wiederum einen Emulator für die...
Naja, eine VM.
Ja, weiß nicht, gibt es eine Raspberry Pi VM?
Soweit ich weiß nicht.
Naja, also ich sag dir, wenn du mit Elixir arbeitest, ist das eigentlich ziemlich
egal, weil du hast halt, du hast ja eh schon eine VM.
Also du fährst da alles in der Erlang VM und da gibt es dann keine nennenswerten
Unterschiede zwischen wie es auf deinem Host läuft und wie es auf diesem Device läuft.
Das einzige Problem ist, du willst es halt alles klein genug zusammenbekommen
und mit einem stabilen Betriebssystemmantel ausstatten. Und das ist halt das, was Nervs dir abnimmt.
Nervs baut dir quasi für deinen Bedarf ein Minimal-Linux zusammen.
Also nur das absolut Nötige an Komponenten, was du eben brauchst für diese Plattform
und um deine Erlang-VM und was diese Erlang-VM selber noch an Dingen zugreifen will.
Also was weiß ich, wenn du Bluetooth brauchst, dann muss dann halt irgendwie
auch der Bluetooth-Tack dabei sein, aber wenn du ihn nicht brauchst,
dann ist er dann vielleicht in diesem Linux gar nicht erst drin.
Also so das dünnschaligste Linux, was du brauchst, um überhaupt das Ding zum
Booten zu bekommen und die Erlang-VM zu starten und ab dann bist du ohnehin nur in der Erlang-VM.
Und genau, das ist so das eine, was NERVS macht, was NERVS außerdem noch hat,
ist so ein begleitendes Projekt, das heißt NERVS Hub,
das ist eine Software, die, wie dein Name schon andeutet,
dafür sorgt, dass du so eine komplette Flotte von diesen NERVS IoT Devices remote überwachen kannst.
Das bedeutet, sagen wir mal, du hast jetzt diese Installation,
die ich ansprach, Du hast jetzt irgendwie diese ganzen Devices in tausend Wohnungen, wo du ja auch,
dass du normalerweise keine Techniker vor Ort hast. Die muss halt einfach immer
laufen. Du musst immer wissen, leben die noch?
Und wenn es irgendwie Security-Update gibt, dann brauchen die auch alle neue Firmware.
Und du willst halt auch sehen, sind die irgendwie online oder gab es da gerade Stromausfall?
All diese ganzen Sachen, dieses ganze Monitoring von vielen kleinen Geräten.
Und das macht dann halt dieser NERVS-Hub. Das heißt, in diesem NERVS ist gleich die Software mit dabei,
dass das Gerät mehr oder weniger seine ganze Telemetrie und seinen Status und
auch die Möglichkeit für Remote Access und vor allem auch für Firmware-Update
über diesen Hub managbar zu machen.
Sprich, du hast dann eben diese Software auf deinem Server laufen oder du benutzt
irgendwie einen fertigen Dienst, wie zum Beispiel des Nervs Cloud.
Und kannst dann da deine Devices dort anmelden mit allen möglichen Security-Strategien,
also etwa mit einem Key und was hatten die da noch?
Da war doch noch irgendwie so eine da muss ich doch irgendwie fett drüber unterhalten,
weiß ich jetzt gerade nicht mehr so ganz genau, wie sie die Sicherheit noch
weiter steigern wollen, aber wie auch immer, also du kannst das dann eben so
konfigurieren, wie du möchtest.
Ja, und dann hast du quasi im Web einen Überblick über deine komplette Flotte.
Und wenn die halt neue Firmware braucht, dann stellst du diese Firmware einfach
auf deinem Hub bereit und die Kisten updaten sich dann automatisch so und booten neu und ja.
Die machen aber nur ihr eigenes Protokoll, oder? Oder machen die auch sowas
wie Thread und Matter und diese ganzen anderen Standards?
Das hat ja jetzt erstmal mit dem Funk lokal so nichts zu tun.
Das ist jetzt hier einfach Ja.
Thread ist ja ein Funk.
Ja, aber darüber machst du ja nicht Internet.
Ja, du machst damit zumindest keine Bandbreite.
Ob deine Geräte Thread haben, ist ja nochmal eine ganz andere Frage.
Inwiefern du damit jetzt so Smart Home kompatible Protokolle mit deiner Hardware
implementierst, hat jetzt erstmal mit NERVs nichts zu tun.
NERVs sagt einfach nur, wir kümmern uns um das Deployment und um die Überwachung
und über die Möglichkeit, die ganze Firmware remote auszuspielen,
alle Geräte aktiv zu halten, zu warnen, wenn irgendwas down ist und so weiter.
Also es ist mehr so das Flottenmanagement, ganz unabhängig davon,
ob das jetzt Smart Home ist oder was auch immer. Es kann ja auch irgendwas anderes sein.
Es können einfach irgendwelche Server sein, es kann irgendwelche,
was auch immer du halt auf deinen kleinen Devices fahren möchtest.
Solange du das als Target hast in NERVs, also die Hardware unterstützt wird,
wird halt auch so BeagleBone und all diese ganzen Sachen unterstützt.
Gibt es das noch?
Ja, klar.
Ich glaube schon.
Die BeagleBones sind auch nach wie vor coole Plattformen.
Also die können so einiges, was Raspberry Pis nicht so ohne weiteres können.
genau, also das war dieses NERVs Projekt und das ist einfach an sich ist das
so ein totales Highlight in diesem Ökosystem,
weil es halt einfach dir es relativ einfach macht, auf so kleine Devices zu
deployen, ohne dass du dir groß einen abbrechen musst,
und auch dieses,
automatisch gesteuerte Auto basiert da drauf und es sind auch viele andere Sachen,
vorgestellt worden, die halt damit auch laufen.
Darum ging es ja letzten Endes an dem ersten Tag auch.
Genau, und dann gab es aber noch ein, wie das eben so auf Hacker-Konferenzen so ist, ein Badge,
Und wir hatten ja auch irgendwie letztes Mal ordentlich über den letzten Batch,
den wir da gesehen haben in Holland gerantet, weil das alles so überhand genommen hat.
Wir haben immer mal wieder über Batches gerantet.
Wir haben immer mal wieder über Batches gerantet, genau.
Ich erinnere.
Weil die ja immer so nicht so auf den Bedarf der Veranstaltung hin zugeschnitten
waren, in meiner Sicht zumindest.
Ja und in der Regel auch sehr mit der heißen Nadel gestrickt.
Genau, mit der heißen Nadel gestrickt, was man oft auch gut verstehen kann,
weil die Zeit ist knapp und die Motivation mag so sein.
Ist manchmal zu knapp, genau.
Genau. Und so eine heiße Nadel gab es hier auch auf der Gottmeier,
weil es gibt da ein Open-Hardware-Projekt, das heißt Trellis von einem netten Kerl aus Luxemburg.
Brutolux Electronics und der macht halt dedizierte Open Source Hardware Designs,
speziell mit dem Ziel mit NERVs eingesetzt zu werden.
Also es ist sozusagen Hardware, die jetzt auch mal so explizit auf den Einsatz
mit Erlang Elixier gedacht ist und dafür sozusagen jetzt als Open Source Projekt gestartet ist.
Und davon gab es so ein Device, das kannst du dir mal vorstellen, Luca.
Genau, ich halte es einmal für Roddy, für die Kamera.
Alle anderen sehen nichts.
Genau, alle anderen sehen nichts, aber wir können beschreiben, was es zu sehen gibt.
Man sieht, es ist ein E-Ink-Display, ein ziemlich großes.
In einem Kasten, auch nicht ganz klein.
Ja, es ist nicht ganz der Klopper.
es ist nicht von Gas selbst gedruckt, aber ich glaube von der Firma,
die das angefertigt hat.
Das Case hat vorne eine kleine oder eine große Aussparung für das Display.
Auf der Rückseite ist die Platine.
Also die Platine ist die Rückseite davon.
An der Seite gibt es zwei kleine Knöpfe und einen An-Ausschalter und einen USB-C-Port.
Und man kann das Ding aufklappen. Das ist so scharniermäßig lässt sich das öffnen.
Und dann kann man da reinschauen und die sehen, dass die größte Komponente,
die Batterie ist da drin.
Das will man ja wohl auch. Soll ja auch eine Weile lang halten, oder?
Tut's auch, weil es ist ein E-Ink-Display. Verbraucht wenig Strom.
Wahrscheinlich so gut wie gar keinen, wenn es nicht geupdatet wird.
Es ist ein kleiner, es gibt ein Wi-Fi-Chip da drauf.
ein, man hat vergessen, was das für ein Prozessor war, irgendwie so ein Allwinner T113 steht da drauf.
Genau, ein Allwinner T113 S4.
Das ist ein ARMV7 Ding, was jetzt nicht besonders schnell ist oder so,
aber es reicht halt um Nerves und also beziehungsweise es reicht um ein Linux
da drauf zu booten, ein kleines.
1,2 Gigahertz Dual Core Cortex A7.
Okay.
Mit 256 Megabyte On-Chip-Ram.
Okay, ja, das ist nicht viel.
Das ist, glaube ich, eher der Punkt, wo es kritisch wird.
Aber es ist über dieser ESP32-Mikrocontroller- Geschichte.
Also unter dem Raspberry hast du ja normalerweise nur diese ganz kleinen Dinger
und das siedelt sich sozusagen noch mal so ein bisschen dazwischen an.
Gut, du hast noch den Arduino, aber der spricht von Kilobytes.
Genau, das meine ich. Also die ganz kleinen Teile.
Aber der ESP, der hat, glaube ich, auch eher einen Megabyte-Bereich.
Ja, aber halt auch, je nachdem, so 8 bis 16 vielleicht. Also je nach...
Ja gut, aber das ist auch kein Prozessor, auf den man in Linux fährt. Also ganz ehrlich.
Genau, also ich weiß nicht, ob das geht. Ja, gehen tut alles,
aber ich glaube nicht, dass man das macht.
So, dieser Batch, der ist jetzt allerdings powerful. Der hat genug Kraft,
um da Linux zu booten. Es bootet bestimmt irgendwie 45 Sekunden.
Schnell geht es jetzt auch nicht.
Aber das Tolle ist ja, das ist ein E-Link-Display. Mein Badge hier ist ausgeschaltet
und man sieht trotzdem noch das Main-Feature.
Mein Name steht da immer noch auf dem Display drauf.
Wenn man das angeschaltet hat auf der Konferenz, dann hat sich das dort in das
Konferenz-WLAN reingewählt und auf einen Web-Server connected.
Das ist so die zweite Software-Komponente von diesem Projekt.
eine Phoenix basierte Web-Anwendung ist das, die ein Web-Socket aufmacht,
zu dem sich dann die ganzen Badges connecten können, das hat auf der Konferenz
mäßig gut funktioniert, wegen schlechten WLAN.
Aber es gab auch noch ein paar Devices, die mussten auch nochmal geflasht werden,
da war irgendwie noch so ein Bug stimmt das auch, das war die heiße Nadel,
aber es hat an sich ganz gut funktioniert.
Stimmt, also wenn man ins WLAN kam, die Connection gut war, dann hat das ganz gut funktioniert.
Jetzt ist halt die Frage, wie setzt man da den Namen auf so ein Name-Badge,
wenn man nur zwei Buttons hat an dem Gerät.
Das fand ich war wirklich cool gelöst. Es gibt so eine,
Navigation durch quasi Apps, die man machen kann, mit dem einen Button,
mit dem anderen Button interagiert man dann mit der App und es gibt eine Settings-App,
zu der kann man navigieren, die kann man starten und dann zeigt das Ding einen QR-Code an.
Und in diesem QR-Code steht eine URL drin zu diesem Web-Server.
der einen Token mit dran hat. Und wenn man auf diese URL dann geht,
dann kriegt man dort die Settings-Seite sozusagen für das Gerät angezeigt.
Und sobald man die Settings dort dann speichert, kriegt das Gerät das über den
Websocket mitgeteilt und setzt sich dann die Einstellung dementsprechend.
Also die ganzen Infos, die man auf dem Name-Badge anzeigen möchte.
Der Web-Server läuft jetzt auf dem Badge?
Nee, der Web-Server läuft irgendwo.
Das heißt, der funktioniert auch ohne diesen Web-Server nicht so wirklich.
Ja, es funktioniert, aber du kannst dann halt keine Änderung machen,
weil du hast ja keine Eingabegeräte.
Du hast ja nur zwei Buttons und theoretisch kannst du es über USB-C natürlich auch noch machen.
Das wäre die andere Variante, dass du da noch einen Web-Server auf dem Batch laufen lassen kannst.
Das ist kein Problem, weil du hast ja komplettes Elixier und da kannst du auch
Phoenix-Web-Server problemlos laufen lassen.
Also es wäre auch möglich, ist auch so, wenn du das Ding über USB-C an den Rechner
anschließt, dann macht er automatisch Ethernet da drüber.
Das heißt, du steckst hier mit USB-C an deinen Rechner und dann hast du da quasi
eine Ethernet-Emulation,
und kannst direkt auf device-name.local draufgehen mit SSH,
oder, also du könntest über SSH ein einfaches Text-Interface machen,
das gab's jetzt so nicht, aber das wäre halt der andere Weg,
dass man das jetzt ohne Webserver macht.
Aber das ist halt auch ganz cool, weil eben der Server ist ja quasi nur eine
verlängerte Tastatur, der speichert selber gar nichts.
Also es gab keine Accounts oder so, wo dann irgendwie deine Namen gespeichert sind,
sondern du hast es eigentlich nur in dem Moment als erweiterte Tastatur benutzt,
also den Webserver quasi als Tastatur für dein Device, um einmal diese Settings
da reinzuschreiben oder zu ändern.
Und das war es dann halt eigentlich auch. Also es war schon sehr pfiffig und auch sehr einfach.
Der Code ist auch natürlich alles Open Source.
Und das Ding ist einfach, das ist quasi so ein Device, das ist einfach zum Rumprobieren
und eben dafür gemacht, um mit Elixier und dann eben auch konkret mit NERVs
zu lernen, wie das irgendwie alles funktioniert.
Weil du lädst es runter, dann musst du ja erstmal deine Firmware,
also wenn du es neu machen willst, dann musst du halt die Firmware brennen und da draufschreiben.
Wie war das? Ah ja genau, das ist nämlich noch so ein anderes Teil,
das Teil, wenn du das über USB-C anmeldest, man muss, wie war das jetzt?
Was war denn der letzte Stand?
Ah ja genau, du musst es ausschalten und auf der Platine gibt es nochmal so einen kleinen Button.
Wenn du den drückst beim Einschalten, dann kommt das Ding auch quasi wie eine SD-Karte hoch.
Das heißt, es meldet sich dem Rechner gegenüber als SD-Karte und dann kannst
du eben mit MixBurn direkt dein neues Image da so drauf schrauben,
ohne wirklich eine SD-Karte zu verwenden, weil die gibt es da halt auch nicht drin.
Das ist schon ganz fancy.
Das Coole an Nerfs ist dann an der Stelle, sobald du einmal so ein Image quasi
per Hand auf die SD-Karte, auch wenn sie jetzt virtuell ist,
draufgebrannt hast, dann,
jedenfalls, sofern man es so konfiguriert hat, wird der SSH Public Key,
den man dort SSH verzeichnet, liegt da mit drauf kopiert ins Image,
und dann kann man ab dann auch per SSH drauf connecten und per SSH auch ein
Firmware-Update machen.
Und läuft Doom schon drauf?
Naja, auf so einem E-Ink-Display macht das nur Begrenz-Spaß.
Challenge accepted, oder?
Aber was drauf läuft, ist Luca.
Rickroll. Willst du darauf hinaus?
Darauf wollte ich hinaus, genau. Es gab nämlich ein, wie hieß das?
Es gab ein, ja, in den Settings-Menü, da gab es so ein Easter Egg,
da gab es so ein Ding, das hieß irgendwie Sudo, Enter Sudo-Mode.
Genau.
Und wenn du das machst, dann kommt dieser Rick Astley, der mit einer sehr niedrigen Framerate tanzt.
Mit Dithering konnte man auf diesem Websever auch so Fotos hochladen von der
Veranstaltung, die dann freigeschaltet wurden.
Da gab es eine Gallery-App und die hat sich dann diese Bilder runtergeladen
und dann halt so in so einem schwarz-weiß-monochromen Dithering-Style präsentiert,
was auch sehr schick aussieht.
Also dieses Ehen-Teil hat irgendwie 300x400 Pixel, also ganz brauchbare Auflösung.
Das lässt sich alles sehr gut lesen.
Ja, und das war eine sehr schöne Idee und die hat uns so gut gefallen,
dass wir gleich gefragt haben, ob wir da vielleicht noch ein paar von haben
können, weil das wäre doch mal ganz cool,
das da mit rum zu spielen auf dem Kongress und der Gast, der das macht,
der hat tatsächlich jetzt auch kurzfristig, weil er nochmal auf einer anderen
Konferenz da mit ist, nochmal so eine Nachproduktion und da fallen dann nochmal so, naja,
25 Stück irgendwie bei raus.
Und ich hatte das auch schon auf Macedon gepostet und gesagt,
wir wollen da vielleicht auf dem Kongress ein bisschen mit rumspielen und wer
sich dafür interessiert, was zu entwickeln.
Da werden wir dann dafür sorgen, dass Leute eins bekommen können.
Ich sage mal gleich dazu, uns geht es jetzt nicht darum, ein cooles Batch,
mit dem man dann toll rumlaufen kann, also das kann man dann auch,
aber dafür haben wir einfach nicht genug von diesen Dingern,
sondern wir wollen jetzt explizit Leute finden,
die also entweder schon mit Elixier Erfahrungen haben und im Idealfall natürlich
auch Nerves, auch wenn das jetzt keine Voraussetzung ist oder zumindest Bock
haben, sich da mal reinzufummeln.
Also jetzt auch nicht vielleicht irgendwann mal vielleicht unter Umständen oder
so, sondern schon eben jetzt mal so das zum Anlass nehmen, das dann auch vielleicht
mal wirklich zu tun, wenn man das vielleicht vorher immer nur so ein bisschen im Auge hatte,
weil man kann da halt mit der bestehenden Software schon mal relativ viel zum
Laufen bekommen und dann auch schnell einfach mal diesen ganzen Prozess machen
und hat danach einfach so ein schönes Teil.
Das eigentliche Ziel von diesem Badge ist, das soll noch ein bisschen weiterentwickelt
werden, weil es ist halt derzeit alles noch so Prototyp.
Da fehlt noch so einiges drauf. Die Hardware soll sich noch verbessern.
Und nächstes Jahr soll da quasi so ein Starter-Kit draus werden für NERVs, also sozusagen,
um einfach in diesem NERVs-Projekt mal was zu haben, was jetzt nicht immer nur
ein Raspberry Pi ist und vielleicht auch nicht so teuer ist jetzt wie ein Raspberry
Pi, wobei so teuer sind die ja jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Kosten die 30 Euro oder so?
War es ein Raspberry Pi, der alte oder was? Ein neuer kostet eher so 80, 90.
Was ist denn ein neuer?
Ein Fünfer.
Ja, kostet so viel?
Ja.
Die Zeros sind günstiger, die sind vielleicht eher vergleichbar,
was die Hardware angeht.
Meinst du? Ist das so?
Ja, die haben weniger Power. Also der Zero 2, der hat glaube ich so viel Power
wie der Raspberry Pi 2 meines.
Ja, es geht ja nicht nur um Power. Wir haben ja auch noch ein halbes Gigabyte Flash mit drauf.
Das haben wir vorhin gar nicht gesagt. Und halt 256 Megabyte RAM.
Also es ist schon so Mittelklasse in diesem Controller-Bereich.
Egal, also das muss man sehen. Das Ding liegt ja so derzeit bei knapp 30 Euro so in der Produktion.
Vielleicht wird es ja auch noch billiger. Ich gucke gerade mal hier.
Raspberry Pi 5 neu, irgendwie 81 Euro und ein Raspberry Pi 4 60 Euro.
Okay.
Das ist so spannend, wie viel diese ESPs kosten. Die kriegst du ja für neun Euro irgendwie.
Ja klar, aber dann hast du halt auch nicht wirklich ein komplettes Gerät.
Und schon gar nicht mit so einem E-Ink-Display, weil das ist ja eigentlich die klinige Geschichte.
Die ESPs, ich finde es nur spannend, wie viel billiger sind.
Die sind als so ein Arduino, der wiederum noch viel weniger kann als ein ESP.
Also das war etwas, was mich immer gewundert hat. Aber naja.
Ja gut, ich meine, Arduino gibt es ja dann auch schon wiederum sehr lange und
die Kosten sind ja nicht nur die Hardware, das ist ja auch was organisatorisch drumherum ist.
Auf jeden Fall tut sich da eine ganze Menge und die Devices werden jetzt immer
fähiger, aber wenn man eh noch eine Raspberry Pi in der Schublade hat,
kann man natürlich da auch genauso mit Nervs loslegen.
Also nicht jeder irgendwo in Raspberry Pi Schublade.
Nicht jeder, aber zunehmendem Maße ist das so etwas, was man noch so in der
Schublade rumliegen hat, wenn man es ernst meint.
Und dann ist es natürlich besonders einfach, da mit Elixir und Nervs zu starten,
weil du halt einfach, ja sagst, Nervs hier, Target, Raspberry Pi,
dann legst du eine SD-Karte ein, hast dein Firmware-Image,
schiebst die SD-Karte in Raspi und schon hast du da ein komplettes Environment
und kannst einfach loslegen.
Man muss natürlich sagen, du hast prinzipbedingt durch die Erlang-VM natürlich
nicht so einen unmittelbaren direkten Zugang zu vielen Komponenten.
Also klar, so GPIO ja schon auch, aber für manche Sachen muss man dann eben
schauen, wie man da den Hardware-Support bekommt. Wobei jetzt der,
Das Batch soll schon in der finalen Version nächstes Jahr irgendwann dann auch
so Zugang zu diesen SPI Bussen und so weiter bekommen.
Also noch sehr viel mehr Output, das war jetzt am meisten Prototyp noch nicht so drin.
Also nochmal kurz gesagt, wer Bock hat, wer auf den Kongress kommt und wer Bock
hat ein bisschen an diesem Ding vielleicht mitzubasteln, wir haben jetzt keinen,
richtigen Plan oder so, was wir machen wollen, sondern wir wollen erstmal gucken,
Wer hätte Bock, irgendwie überhaupt was zu machen.
Das für sich mal selber zum Laufen zu bekommen und dann kann man ja vielleicht
auch mal auf Ideen kommen.
Die Dinger sind dann ab November, Anfang November wahrscheinlich verfügbar und
dann ist halt einfach auch noch schön Zeit, um vor dem Kongress ein bisschen was zu basteln.
Das wird jetzt keine große Sache sein und es werden nicht alle Leute auf dem
Kongress mit diesem Ding rumlaufen, darum geht es nicht, sondern halt einfach,
wer Bock hat, da mal ein bisschen mit rumzuspielen.
Be my guest. Schickt mir einfach eine Mail, timetbritlove.org und ich mache
euch auf eine Liste und schicke dann später nochmal eine Mail an alle und dann
gucken wir mal, wie es so aussieht.
Aber schreibt bitte gleich mal dazu, dass ihr da sozusagen auch Bock habt zu entwickeln.
Ja, genau. Das vielleicht dazu.
Wollen wir zum Thema E-Ink-Display? Da habe ich dieses Thema von einer ganz
anderen Seite angegangen.
Ja.
Und zwar, mir ist aufgefallen, dass ich einfach zu wenig lese.
Und auch irgendwie nicht reinkomme, weil Bücher sind unhandlich und schwer und haste nicht gesehen.
Und irgendwann habe ich mich dann doch mal zusammen durchgerungen,
einen E-Reader, einen E-Book-Reader mir anzuschaffen.
Und da ich jetzt nicht unbedingt irgendwas von Amazon haben wollte,
war eigentlich die Konkurrenz nur dieses, wie soll ich sagen,
Konsortium Deutscher Buch.
Handelsketten und Läden. Der Tolino, das ist nämlich wirklich spannend,
wusste ich auch nicht, das ist ein Konsortium.
Unter der Führung von Thalia, aber da ist auch Hugendubel dabei und diverse
größere und kleinere Buchhandlungen.
Und man kann tatsächlich auch frei wählen, über welchen Buchhändler man denn
sein E-Book kaufen will.
Beziehungsweise, wenn das kein DRM hat, kannst du es auch einfach so draufladen.
Das ist jetzt dann nicht so fürchterlich schwierig.
Lustigerweise kannst du dir zum Beispiel über Hugendubel dann die Tolino Cloud
klicken oder du kannst es über Thalia machen oder also du kannst dir bei einem
dieser Anbieter halt dann deinen Account machen und dann läuft deine Cloud über diesen Anbieter.
Ich habe jetzt einfach irgendwie mal Hugendubel genommen und was wollte ich eigentlich erzählen?
Achso und es gibt eine iPad App, die zusammen mit diesem ganzen Kram auch ganz wild synkt.
Also ich Ah, da musst du nicht mehr auf dem Gerät lesen. Kannst du über das iPad machen.
Naja, das Ding ist, das ist ein guter Einwand. Das Ding ist,
ich habe halt auch schon Bücher auf dem iPad gelesen.
Und wenn man das tatsächlich versucht, beziehungsweise öfter mal macht,
kommt man auf den Punkt, wo das iPad halt einfach zu schwer ist.
Dieses iPad, was ich habe, ist irgend so ein Pro 10 irgendwas Zoll,
keine Ahnung, ist jetzt auch nicht so richtig wichtig, wiegt halt ziemlich genau 800 Gramm.
Das ist halt fast ein Kilo. Und dann gucke ich mir das an. Ich habe halt extra auf die Waage gelegt.
wie viel wiegt denn mein iPhone?
Ist mit 230 Gramm jetzt auch nicht super schwer, aber es ist immerhin eine Tafel Schokolade.
Und dann ist dieser E-Reader mit nur 170 Gramm jetzt auch nicht super, super leicht.
Aber das, was man dafür kriegt, ich finde es deutlich angenehmer zu halten.
Der Kontrast ist schön von so einem E-Ink-Display.
Ich habe auch ein bisschen geguckt, habe mir das im Laden nochmal angeguckt.
Es gibt ja E-Ink-Displays inzwischen schon in Farbe.
Und dann habe ich mal so nachgelesen und alle sagen so, ja, Farbe schön und
gut, aber erstens ist sie nicht sehr brillant und zweitens mal geht halt der
schöne Kontrast von dem E-Ink-Display flöten.
Wenn du da Farbe hast, alles ist plötzlich nur noch grau.
Und deswegen habe ich mich jetzt für das aktuell kleinste Modell aus dem Hause
Tolino entschieden, dem, wie heißt das Ding? Irgendwas Schein heißt der.
Tolino Schein 5, fünfte Generation.
Und der tut einfach. Also es gibt ein PDF, das will er einfach nicht lesen.
Das ist ihm irgendwie zu schwierig.
Das ist so ein Paper, ein etwas älteres Paper mit dem Namen zur Elektrodynamik
bewegter Körper. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das kennst.
Ist das nicht so ein Klassiker?
Das ist ein Klassiker, ja. Er
ist eigentlich mehr unter seinem Kurse-Namen Relativitätstheorie bekannt.
Kam mir gleich so bekannt vor.
Also wenn ich das mache, dann stürzt das Teil einfach ab.
Ja, Einstein steckt halt keiner.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich habe ein bisschen reingelesen und bin mir nicht sicher,
ob ich da nicht auch abgestürzt bin.
Aber ich habe es halt einfach mal versucht. Ich habe auch mal Noten drauf gemacht,
also ein PDF mit Noten. das funktioniert jetzt ob der Größe des Displays nicht so gut.
Hast du das PDF mal so durch QPDF oder irgendeinen anderen PDF-Filter mal durchgejagt?
Um was zu tun?
Na, wenn du halt einfach mal das durch irgendeine PDF-Software wie zum Beispiel
QPDF auf der Kommandozeile oder halt irgendwie auf dem Mac, gibt es ja auch was weiß ich hier,
diverse so PDF-Kompressoren, das sind ja alles so Tools, die lesen diese PDFs ein,
und schreiben dann quasi eine neue Datei raus und es kann sehr wohl sein,
dass du dir die eine oder andere Inkompatibilität, die dieses Gerät jetzt mit
irgendeinem versteckten Feature hatte, dabei quasi entfernt.
Ja gut, also zumindest jetzt der Einstein ist halt ein Scan,
das kann sein, dass das einfach zu groß ist.
Dann würde sich unter Umständen gerade eine Recompression empfehlen,
weil du dann halt einfach mit kleineren Dateigrößen daherkommst.
Aber man sieht, also Noten brauche ich jetzt nicht zu versuchen bei der Größe des Displays.
Zeig mal. Das ist ja noch nicht mal A6 so richtig.
Nee, es ist noch nicht mal A6. Was aber auch egal ist.
Innsbruck, ich muss dich lassen.
Ja, das ist jetzt einfach nur ein Beispiel.
Wie singt sich das denn? Innsbruck, ich fahre ja gerade nach Innsbruck.
Das ist eigentlich ein Klassiker, den musst du mal googeln.
Ja.
Beziehungsweise auf der Streaming-Plattform deiner Wahl.
Ich fahre dahin.
Mein, ich fahre dahin, wo geht das weiter?
Mein Straßen.
Mein Straßen im fremde Land dahin.
Mein Freud ist mir, wie ist die Seite? Wie mache ich das?
Genommen.
Du tippst auf der Seite, wo du weiterblättern willst.
Genommen, die ich mit weiß bekommen, wo ich im E-Land.
Elend, wo ich im Elend bin.
Also du siehst, für solche PDFs ist es nicht unbedingt geeignet.
Aber ich meine, wenn man sowieso nur Text hat, dann kann man den ja so groß machen, wie man will.
Also ich finde, es liest sich auch, man kann auch die Hintergrundbeleuchtung
hell-dunkel machen. Also ich bin zufrieden damit.
Es ist halt ein Single-Purpose-Device im besten Sinne, weil ich damit auch keine
Audiobooks höre, obwohl das irgendwie geht.
Aber ich meine, warum sollte ich das tun, wenn man ein iPhone hat,
dass das dann doch deutlich besser kann?
Und ja, weiß ich nicht. Also ich bin da zufrieden mit.
Wie lange hält der Akku?
Keine Ahnung. Ich habe es ehrlich gesagt erst einmal aufgeladen und das ist
jetzt irgendwie mehrere Wochen her. Und wir haben jetzt noch 86 Prozent.
Also, ja, weiß nicht, lange, sagen wir mal lange.
Ja, keine Ahnung. Es ist halt dadurch, dass es ein E-Ink-Display ist,
ist es halt auch nicht jetzt super flott oder so,
wenn man hier tatsächlich meint, also es gibt hier so Scrollbalken,
aber er blättert eigentlich immer eine ganze Seite, weil Animationen haben natürlich
irgendwie keinen Sinn und Graustufen,
naja, das habt ihr ja bei dem Badge auch schon, Graustufen gehen zwar irgendwie,
aber sehen nicht geil aus.
Ach, ich finde Dithering sieht geil aus, mal ehrlich.
Dithering hat natürlich so einen gewissen Stil, der irgendwie cool ist,
aber das ist halt wie Computerspiele mit Pixelgrafik,
das ist so die Klassizistik der Computerspiele, wenn man dabei gewesen ist,
wo es nicht anders ging, dann will man es vielleicht nicht.
Pixelgrafik hast du heute immer noch, anders gibt es ja nicht.
Ja, schon, aber inzwischen sind die Pixel so klein, dass man nicht mehr von Pixelgrafik spricht.
Wenn einem die Klötzchen irgendwie ins Gesicht ballern, dann hast du Pixelgrafik für mich.
Und kann jeder mögen oder auch nicht, ist mir ja egal.
Okay, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, was hier...
Zum Thema Dittering, ne?
Das mit dem Innsbruck müssen wir jetzt natürlich erst mal überprüfen,
weil irgendwie muss ich mal wissen, was hier ist.
Das ist ja wie Weihnachten.
Und das hast du in China gesungen?
Nee.
Nee?
Das ist lange her, dass ich das mal gesungen habe. Ich hatte nur das PDF rumliegen
und wollte einfach gucken, ob das, wenn ich jetzt da mal so ein PDF draufwerfe.
Kannst du mir jetzt nicht einfach vor die Nase halten?
Ich mag das Lied, ich habe es auch schon gesungen.
Ja.
Aber jetzt nicht in China.
Okay, gut.
Ja, unser Chorleiter wollte es nicht, habe es ihm vorgeschlagen.
Also an mir lag es nicht.
Genau Noch was, es gibt die Onleihe Man kann irgendwie E-Books ausleihen Aber
ich glaube, das lassen wir uns von Ralf nächstes Mal erklären Wie das geht Und
weil du Dithering sagtest Da muss ich nochmal dieses eine,
Spiel pluggen Das da heißt The Return of the Obra Din das ist ein 3D-Spiel mit
Dithering was völlig absurd aussieht weil es sieht wirklich so aus als würde
ich einen 3D-Shooter auf einem alten Mac spielen oder so also gut,
ist kein Shooter aber das tut ja nichts zur Sache aber es ist tatsächlich Echtzeit
3D-Grafik First Person in schwarz-weiß mit Dithering, also das ist wirklich absurd.
Kann ich empfehlen Ich bin da nicht durchgekommen, weil es wurde mir dann irgendwann zu kompliziert.
Man muss irgendwie, man muss rausfinden, was passiert ist.
Es wird ein bisschen gruselig, es ist ein bisschen Horror, aber im Großen und
Ganzen ist es ein witziges Spiel.
Und wie gesagt, es ist halt echt Zeit.
Return of the Opera Din wurde schon im Chat.
Es ist wirklich absurd, wie gut das funktioniert, dass du schwarz-weiß in Dithering
in 3D mit Flächen, die halt heller oder dunkler sein können.
Also es flimmert auch nicht groß rum, sondern es funktioniert wirklich sehr gut.
Es ist aber auch ein sehr komplexer Prozess, den die da machen.
Also einfach nur so Post-Processing, Dithering auf das fertig gerenderte Bild machen, das geht nicht.
Dann wird es halt super flackern und unstabil aussehen.
Und wie geht es? Er hat irgendwann ein Video oder irgendwie einen länglichen
Blogpost gemacht, wie er das tatsächlich tut, damit es eben nicht flackert,
sondern das Dithering halbwegs stabil ist.
Ich kann es jetzt natürlich nicht wiedergeben und selbst wenn ich könnte,
wollen wir das vielleicht jetzt hier nicht hören.
Also es ist wirklich nicht einfach irgendwie, sondern der hat da verdammt viel
Gehirnschmalz reingehängt, damit das so gut aussieht, wie es aussieht.
Und das war schon immer so schwarz-weiß?
Ja, das Spiel ist so.
Okay.
Das macht aber auch so ein bisschen den Reiz aus,
weil hinter diesem schwarz-weiß geditterten 3D man einfach ganz,
also die eigene Fantasie ganz anders zum Vorschein kommt, weil du ja,
wie gesagt, du versuchst ja rauszufinden, was ist passiert mit diesem Schiff,
was irgendwie angeschwemmt kommt.
alle sind tot und du hast so ein komisches Uhrendevice mit, wo du auf irgendeine
komische Art und Weise in die Vergangenheit zurück gehen kannst,
um dir dann Szenen aus der Vergangenheit anzugucken.
Und ohne jetzt mehr zu spoilern, es ist...
Okay, aber es ist jetzt nicht Prinzessin retten und nicht Autofahren und nicht alle...
Nee, es ist mehr so ein Rätselspiel.
Okay, ist doch schon mal was. Und was meintest du, Luca, mit was einfach so
Dizzern ist, geht nicht?
Ja, also wenn du einfach so ein normales Spiel nimmst und einfach da so ein
Dithering-Effekt drauf klatschst,
dann wirst du, sobald du entweder die Kamera bewegst oder sich Gegenstände im
Bild bewegen, es wird eine super Flicker-Party, also total flackern und unstabil sein.
Also ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau wie der Algorithmus funktioniert,
aber der geht im Prinzip davon aus, dass du versuchst die Teile des Ditherns
so weit wieder zu verwenden,
wie du kannst von Frame zu Frame so dass möglichst viel des Ditherings sich nicht ändert,
statt das jedes Mal komplett neu zu machen,
irgendwie also das.
Ist eine Herausforderung Und wie hat das Spiel das gelöst?
Das kann ich nicht mehr wiedergeben.
Also wie gesagt, der Autor von dem Spiel hat da mal einen Blogpost oder einen...
Nee, ich meine, du hast es ja gespielt.
Nehmen wir an. Ja.
Denen ist es gelungen.
Ja, ja, das funktioniert sehr gut. Man hat nicht das Gefühl,
dass alles krisselt und so, sondern ganz im Gegenteil.
Diese Optik von dem Spiel, die tritt so schnell in den Hintergrund dadurch,
dass du dich ja selber durch diese 3D-Welt bewegst, dass du das eigentliche
Dithern nicht mehr wahrnimmst, innerhalb von Sekunden eigentlich nicht mehr
sondern in dieser sehr einfachen Welt dann drinsteckst das ist wirklich,
extrem faszinierend vom technischen her ob einem das Spiel gefällt ist jetzt
nochmal ein anderes Ding aber es ist auf jeden Fall,
also technisch kann ich wirklich empfehlen sich das mal anzugucken auch wenn
man nicht weit kommt vielleicht weil es ist super faszinierend.
Da habe ich schon mir gerade ein Video an, wo man das sieht, diesen Effekt und ja.
Man kann auch lustigerweise zwischen diversen Settings umschalten,
ob soll aussehen, als wäre es ein C64,
also hellblau, dunkelblau oder ein alter Mac mit wirklich richtig schwarz-weiß
oder irgendwie so ein bisschen Bernstein oder so. Das ist auch sehr lustig.
Sieht geil aus.
Ja.
Cool, gefällt mir.
Return of the Opera Din. Als ich das gelesen hat und gesehen habe,
musste ich es sofort ausprobieren. Das ist auch, glaube ich, nicht wirklich teuer.
Also es ist ja auch nicht nur gedittert, es ist ja auch eine relativ niedrige
Auflösung, die da simuliert wird.
Also man geht noch nicht mal auf die volle mögliche Pixelgröße.
Größe. Vielleicht wäre es dann nicht gedissert genug.
Das kann sein, aber es sieht halt nach Pixelgrafik aus und es bewegt sich halt und ja.
Sieht nach Pixelgrafik aus.
Ja, naja, also wenn man damals dabei war und einen der ersten Macs angeschaltet
hat und dann diese Schwarz-Weiß-Punkte vor sich hatte und plötzlich wurde alles
irgendwie in diesen Schwarz-Weiß-Punkten zusammengebaut, das war halt eine… Ja.
Das ist halt so diese Ästhetik von Adobe Photoshop 1.0.
Das hatte doch dann so ein, wie sagte man, ein Splash-Screen,
der glaube ich auch gedittert war.
Gerade mal, das war doch irgendeine Lady.
Dieses Auge, ne?
Achso, richtig, das Auge. Nee, ich dachte gerade an so ein Gesicht.
Verwechsel ich das jetzt gerade mit was anderem?
Ich glaube, ich habe es gefunden. Das ist so ein Auge in einer Raute.
Ja, das ist in der Tat das. Okay, das meinte ich aber eigentlich nicht.
Ich meinte nicht das Auge, sondern ich meinte so ein...
Aber es ist gedittert.
So eine Frau, oder war das McPaint? War das McPaint?
Ja, genau, das meinte ich. Aber das ist nicht wirklich gedittert.
Ne, okay, gut. Ignoriert mich einfach.
Was man zum Dizzern ja nochmal erwähnen kann, ist das Design vom 37C3 Unlocked.
Das war gedizzert, stimmt. Genau, das war gedizzert.
Da gab es überall Dizzering. Das Hauptlogo war diese, wie nennt sich diese Zange,
das Schneidewerkzeug, das fette.
Eine Ohrzange?
Nein.
Ach, so ein Bolzenschneider, so ein doppelt übersetzter.
Mhm.
Stimmt, da war auch alles im Dithering. Das ist in der Tat ein schönes Element gewesen.
Ja, es ist eine Technologie, die so ein bisschen in Vergessenheit geraten ist. Das Dithern.
Das stimmt, ich hatte das ja hier auch so ein bisschen, als ich mit meinem Flip-Dot-Display
rumgespielt habe. aber das ist ja auch so dramatisch, Low-Res, Monochrom.
Und wenn du da irgendwie Farbverläufe machen willst, dann musst du halt entsprechend
das auch so randomisieren.
Monochromverläufe.
Mit wahrscheinlich Monochromverläufen.
Von weiß zu schwarz.
Von schwarz zu weiß.
Ja.
So, damit könnten wir mal über Apple reden, oder?
Sollten wir mal mehr über Macs reden, weil es war ja eigentlich gerade großes Gedöns.
Ich fand es ja nur so mittelgroßes Gedöns.
Ja, Gedöns, du weißt schon, was ich meine. Also Apple machte halt Gedöns und
früher sind wir ja alle ganz läufig gewesen in dieser Zeit, muss sagen,
das habe ich mir mittlerweile komplett abtrainiert.
Das war diesmal sogar so, ich habe dann zeitversetzt, also etwas später,
nicht jetzt live, als es stattfand, sondern so zwei Stunden später,
als ich in Ruhe irgendwie in meinem Wohnwagen lag und irgendwie Brille auf hatte,
habe ich mir das irgendwie angeschaut und bin dabei eingeschlafen.
So viel dazu.
Gut, ich habe es live gesehen, bin nicht eingeschlafen, war aber glaube ich
nicht immer ganz mit Gedanken bei der Sache.
Nicht spannend ist, ne?
Nee, nee. Nee, es kam auch irgendwie nix. Was war?
Wie, es kam nix.
Es kam ja schon einiges.
Aber es war halt, ich bin einfach ermüdet von dieser Präsentationsform.
Was für mich hängen geblieben ist. Ja, neue iPhones. Was haben die iPhones neu?
Kamera, Prozessor. Sonst war nix neu in den iPhones.
Doch, klar, natürlich. Komplett neues Gehäuse.
Ja gut, neues Gehäuse. und es gibt dieses flache iPhone, wo ich mir jetzt nicht so ganz sicher bin.
Also so ganz flach, aber dann so einen dicken Wulst.
Wo die Kameras drin sind.
Fand ich jetzt irgendwie weird, aber gut, das mag Leute geben,
die das dann geil finden.
Du brauchst die Tiefe, wenn du Kameras irgendwie halbwegs gut performen lassen
willst, dann brauchst du einfach diese Tiefe.
Ja, das ist mir bekannt, das ist mir schon klar. Ich finde es nur trotzdem albern,
dann den Rest so dünn zu machen und dann zu behaupten, oh, dünnestes iPhone ever.
Wenn du dann aber trotzdem den Wulsterst. Aber gut, das müssen Leute entscheiden,
die sowas haben wollen. Ich werde nicht zu denen gehören.
Nee, klar, das ist jetzt nicht für unser eins, aber es mag durchaus einen Markt dafür geben.
Die werden sich sicherlich ein paar Gedanken darüber gemacht haben,
ob das jetzt ein Erfolg wird oder nicht. Das ist mir ehrlich gesagt ziemlich Wumpe.
Es kann natürlich auch sein, dass das einfach nur so ein Because-We-Can Ding
ist, gepaart mit, keine Ahnung, vielleicht bauen wir wirklich nochmal so ein
Club-Telefon und dann ist es schon mal ganz gut, wenn wir die eine Hälfte so
dünn haben und die andere...
Ehrlich gesagt, das ist so dünn, dass ich mir vorstellen kann,
dass manche Leute das auch so klappen. Aber gut, das ist nochmal...
Es ist wohl relativ stabil tatsächlich. Dadurch, dass sie jetzt dieses Gehäuse
so als Unibody machen, ist es wohl ausschließlich an den Antennen...
Mit Titan oder so, ne?
Ja, Alu ist es jetzt.
Die sind jetzt wieder auf Alu gegangen.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das ganz Dünne ist trotzdem Titan, weil es stabil genug
sein muss. So habe ich das in Erinnerung, aber vielleicht...
Ich glaube, die sind jetzt alle ALU und bin mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt bei dem R nicht sicher.
Das Pro hat eine Vapor Chamber, da habe ich ja so lachen müssen, aber gut.
Ja, weil das ist halt ein Kostentreiber im Wesentlichen.
Gut, klar, wenn der Prozessor jetzt nicht mehr so effektiv ist oder sie ihn
tatsächlich in die Geschwindigkeit reinfahren, wo er so heiß wird.
Also wenn es dazu führt, dass dieses Gerät im Sommer auch in der Lage ist,
seine Displayhelligkeit länger zu halten, dann bin ich all for it.
Das ist nämlich das Ding.
Chad sagt, ich habe recht, er ist aus Titan.
Ah, okay, gut, da war ich wahrscheinlich schon eingeschlafen und ich habe es
mir ehrlich gesagt immer noch nicht nochmal angeschaut.
War jetzt auch so ein Detail, ich weiß nicht, warum ich mir das gemerkt habe, ist auch egal.
War auf jeden Fall trotzdem sehr stabil. Es gab natürlich die üblichen Band-Tests
und da hat es ganz gut abgeschnitten.
Noch ein Band-Gate wollen sie sich wahrscheinlich auch nicht eintreten.
Nee, und das kriegen sie mittlerweile ja auch alles irgendwie ganz gut hin.
Mit dem Tolino würde ich auch keinen Band-Test machen.
Siehst du mal.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Kein Vertrauen in die deutsche Buchverlage.
Es ist nicht das Device für einen Band-Test.
Die meisten Devices sind eigentlich für einen Band-Test gemacht.
Also die Vapor Chamber, ich fand sie insofern interessant, als,
mir ist nicht bekannt, naja, ein iPhone mit Vapor Chamber haben sie noch nie gemacht.
Ich glaube so Mac Minis und MacBooks haben durchaus eine Vapor Chamber gehabt,
das ist ja Stand der Technik eigentlich. Das macht irgendwie jeder,
auch wenn es, wie gesagt, ein Kostentreiber ist.
Wenn du drum rum kommst, machst du es halt nicht.
Dass das so fürchterlich viel bringt, wundert mich ein bisschen.
Also dann muss da schon auch ganz schön ordentlich viel Wärme aus dem Prozessor
kommen und dann auch entsprechend an das Alugehäuse abgegeben werden.
Also ich nehme mal an, wenn man das dann benutzt, will man vielleicht irgendwie
kein Case haben, was irgendwie dann thermoisoliert, weil sonst hat die ganze
Vapor Chamber keinen Sinn.
Aber wir werden sehen.
Für mich ist nichts.
Mir ist die Technologie ehrlich gesagt egal, wenn das Ding dadurch kälter wird,
am All-For-It, weil das ist halt ein echtes Problem im Sommer,
wenn da die Sonne drauf scheint, dann ist halt schnell Schluss und dann wird
das Display gedimmt, damit nicht
so viel Strom verbraucht wird oder nicht zusätzliche Wärme erzeugt wird.
Vom Langsamer werden mal ganz abgesehen.
Aber es kühlt ja nicht aktiv. Also es ist ja nicht so, dass irgendwo ein Lüfter
anspringt und dann Luft einsaugt und die Wärme ableitet.
Du bist ja kein Lüfter.
Nee, aber die Vapor Chamber alleine bedeutet ja eigentlich nur,
dass die Wärme vom Prozessor, der dann wahrscheinlich relativ heiß wird,
relativ effektiv an die Rückwand von dem Gehäuse abgeleitet wird.
Ja, aber die Rückwand ist ja bei dem Pro jetzt das gesamte.
Das ist ein Unibody.
Das heißt das verteilt.
Ja gut, es war bei den anderen auch nicht viel anders, nur dass sie wahrscheinlich
nicht eine entsprechend effektive
Wärmeleitung zwischen Prozessor und der Rückwand hatten. Wie auch immer.
Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wenn du das im Auto unter der Sonne lässt,
dass es trotzdem heiß genug wird, als dass es das Display dimmt.
Ja, irgendwann schon. Die Frage ist halt, wie schnell? Also schaffen sie es
sozusagen länger cool zu bleiben?
Also in dem Fall würde ich sagen nein. In dem Fall, wo du, weiß ich nicht,
eine sehr stark 3D-lastige Anwendung oder mit Kamera und weiß ich nicht,
irgendwas benutzt, wo der Prozessor ordentlich gefordert ist,
kann ich mir das eher vorstellen.
Da merkst du halt, in der Hand wird es warm, aber der Prozessor muss nicht irgendwie
sich einschränken, weil er seine Wärme nicht los wird.
Hast du die schon gesehen, Luca, die Geräte? Hast du die schon in der Hand gehabt?
In echt noch nicht, ne.
Okay.
Hat mich jetzt auch nicht so interessiert, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, es ist irgendwie ein bisschen langweilig geworden, ne? Aber, na gut.
Wichtiger ist ja, was sich bei den Betriebssystemen getan hat, die ganze 26er Front.
Eine Hardware-Sache, die fand ich tatsächlich spannend. Und zwar,
das sind die neuen AirPods.
Dadurch, dass sie angeblich doppelt
so gut dämmen und doppelt so gut Noise Cancelling machen und so weiter.
Gut, ich habe es jetzt noch nirgendwo ausprobiert oder so. Gut,
die anderen haben ja auch nie ausprobiert.
Ich erwäge ernsthaft tatsächlich, weil für mich die AirPods auch immer wieder
quasi Gehörschutz sind in diversen Situationen,
das mit den AirPods 3, das mal auszuprobieren, wie gut die denn ein Gehörschutz sind.
Also das Schöne auf Konzerten ist, wenn du die AirPods drin hast und sie dann
auf Transparent schaltest, dass du tatsächlich einen sehr, sehr guten Sound bekommst,
der aber nicht so ist, dass er dir irgendwie die Trommelfälle wegbläst,
weil im Prinzip im Transparency-Mode er irgendwie doch noch cancelt.
Also das ist, keine Ahnung, also das fände ich zumindest geil.
Du hast ja mindestens die passive Dämmung beim Transparency-Mode immer noch dabei.
Genau, genau. Und deswegen bin ich am überlegen, das wäre für mich das Produkt,
wo ich jetzt sagen würde, ja, die anderen Features, die sie da reingebaut haben,
interessieren mich jetzt weniger, aber
einfach das deutlich verbesserte Noise-Canceling, das wäre was für mich.
Also gut, dass du das erwähnst. Für mich war das so selbstverständlich, dass ich die bestelle.
Da habe ich sofort geklickt, da habe ich gar nicht groß drüber nachgedacht.
Ach, du hast schon geklickt.
Ich habe schon geklickt, aber noch nicht empfangen.
Ich finde ja nach wie vor, dass die AirPods Pro sind wahrscheinlich das beste
Produkt, was Apple rausgebracht hat so in den letzten Jahren.
Also es ist einfach irre.
Die Dinger haben vor allem konstant overdelivert.
Also sie waren immer besser und haben dann noch mehr Features bekommen,
die noch nicht mal angekündigt waren.
Ist ja jetzt auch wieder so, jetzt kommt diese Live-Translation,
natürlich nicht in Europa,
Theoretisch dazu.
Und auch diese ganzen anderen Details mit Transparenz, Verbesserung und so weiter,
diese ganzen Modi und so, das war ja, als sie vorgestellt wurden,
waren nicht alle Features, die es heute gibt, schon da.
Und von daher hat sich so der Wert der Teile extrem gesteigert.
Gut, gilt natürlich auch für die iPhones, die Software-Updates bekommen und
dann neue Features haben, aber bei so einem kleinen Kupferrateil würde man das
jetzt nicht unbedingt erwarten, aber es ist auf jeden Fall alles konstant besser geworden.
Und ja, ich war schon bei den ersten Airpod Pros sehr beeindruckt mit Noise Cancellation.
Die 2er war definitiv nochmal besser und wenn sie es auch nur um ein paar Prozent
steigern können, hat sich das wahrscheinlich schon gelohnt.
Ich finde auch die Integration ins Ökosystem von diesen Airpods ist allein schon wert.
Die zu haben. meinte es nämlich gerade im Chat, das hatte ich jetzt nämlich
gerade vergessen, diese Hörhilfe, das war nämlich zum Beispiel so ein Feature,
was später noch dazugehoben.
Das habe ich mal ausprobiert, das war ein bisschen schmerzhaft.
Aber wo es geil ist, ist wenn du so, was weiß ich, so Elternabendsituationen
hast, weißt du, viele Leute in so einem Raum und vorne Musik hören.
Die ganze Zeit, ne?
Nein, vorne wispert irgend so eine Person und es gibt keine richtige Verstärkung,
weil natürlich keiner in Deutschland darüber nachdenken, mal vielleicht einen
Lautsprecher oder sowas mitzubringen.
Okay, Schulen immer schlecht ausgerüstet, wie auch immer. Wenn du also dann
ganz hinten sitzt, weil du natürlich zu spät gekommen bist, dann verstehst du
halt unter Umständen nichts.
Dann kannst du einfach das iPhone vorne auf den Tisch legen und mit den AirPods,
zwar mit etwas Zeitverzögerung, aber immerhin kriegst du es dann quasi per Bluetooth
möglichst schnell nachgereicht.
Es wäre auch nochmal interessant zu sehen, ob sie da vielleicht an der Tens
noch weiter gedreht haben, weil das ist wirklich ein cooles Feature. Echt praktisch.
Ja, okay, gut. Software? Oder hast du noch was zur Hardware?
Die Uhr war wiederum nicht so spannend.
Nö, das ist nur so Modellpflege. Genau.
Wer hat denn alles schon auf 26 aktualisiert?
Alles komplett durch aktualisiert?
Alle Geräte.
Ich auch.
Ich habe gerade noch rechtzeitig das Lade-die-Beta-runter wieder ausgeschaltet,
sonst säße ich hier so halb mit 26.1 schon.
Gibt es das schon?
Jaja, seit heute, gestern.
Okay, das werde ich mir vielleicht auf dem Laptop sogar mal machen,
weil da ist es noch ein bisschen schmerzhaft mit dem macOS.
Echt?
Wie ist eure Erfahrung?
Ich habe kein Problem damit.
Also ich habe weiterhin ein Problem mit dem Liquid Glass, aber jetzt funktionale
Probleme habe ich nicht.
Das Liquid Glass stört mich nicht wirklich, muss ich sagen.
Settings, Bedienungshilfen, Transparenz reduzieren heißt das Feature,
was du einschalten möchtest und dann stört das alles nicht mehr.
Macht mir das bei den Fenstern auch die Radien gleich?
Die Radien?
Ja, also es gibt, je nachdem, ob deine App eine Toolbar hat oder was auch immer
für eine Bar, ich kenne mich da nicht so ganz gut aus mit den ganzen UI-Komponenten,
hast du einen unterschiedlichen Radius am Fenster.
Es gibt da so ein paar Screenshots, wo Leute irgendwie mehrere Fenster übereinander
legen und dann ein Screenshot von der Ecke machen.
Und dann siehst du irgendwie, dass da vier Fenster übereinander liegen,
wo jedes Fenster einen eigenen Corner-Radius hat.
Absolut bizarr.
Meine Vermutung wäre da, dass es vor allen Dingen auch daran liegt,
ob du jetzt schon für 26 kompiliert hast oder nicht.
Ob du dann das neue Design bekommst.
Ja, also zum Teil ja.
Also Apple-Software?
Okay. Ist mir ehrlich gesagt noch nicht aufgefallen.
Ich dachte, ich störe mich generell an diesen neuen Radi, aber man gewöhnt sich ja schnell an alles.
Auch die neue Menü-Optik.
und generell muss ich sagen, ich bin ein großer Freund von diesen kleinen Icons in den Menü-Einträgen.
Manche sagen, es erhöht ein bisschen den Clutter, den Visual Clutter,
also macht alles ein bisschen unübersichtlicher.
Der Argumentation kann ich folgen.
Der kann ich auch folgen, aber ich finde es trotzdem praktisch.
Vor allem, wenn man mal an so einem Mac sitzt, der irgendwie unter Umständen
in einer anderen Sprache konfiguriert ist, als man das normalerweise macht,
dass man über solche Hinweise dann doch sehr dankbar.
Da nimmt man dann Deep L und guckt einfach nach.
Was es da ist. Ja, das kann ich mir dann halt auch sparen.
Aber gab es die vorher nicht? Nee, die sind tatsächlich neu.
Das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Und generell muss ich sagen, also ich war vor allem überrascht,
auf meinem iPhone habe ich das als letztes installiert.
Ich auch, ja.
Und ich muss sagen, mir gefällt das. Also ich dachte ja, ich würde es hassen, aber ich finde es geil.
Und zwar ich habe diese Transparenzgeschichte auch auf dem iPhone,
also überall habe ich irgendwie Apple Intelligence und Transparenz ausgeschaltet.
So, das irgendwie mit diesem Apple AI, der mir die ganze Zeit in meine Messages
reingeht und möchte, dass ich mich wie so ein Honk äußere, da komme ich nicht mit klar.
Ihr wisst, was ich meine? Wenn du diese Apple Intelligence einschaltest,
dann schlägt der dir permanent vor, irgendjemand schreibt dir was und dann so, ja, alles klar.
Also du redest auf einmal wie so ein Tourist, wenn du diese Vorschläge übernimmst
und du kannst das nicht mal ausschalten.
Die habe ich, ehrlich gesagt, noch gar nicht gesehen.
Man kann nur alles ausschalten und das habe ich dann auch getan,
weil das geht gar nicht. Also ich hasse.
Aber vielleicht ist mein Apple Intelligence auch noch nicht richtig konfiguriert oder so.
Das kann man nicht konfigurieren. Das kann man nur einschalten oder ausschalten. So sieht es nämlich aus.
Ja, aber ich war überrascht, dass mich diese ganze Fluptität,
also die Liquidität, sagt man das so?
Flüssigkeit, Fluptizität, die Viskosität. Ja, das ist ja mehr so die Liquidität,
das ist mehr so diese Flüssigkeit.
Schwappdizität.
Ich mag das, ganz ehrlich, weil es ist,
ich finde, User-Interfaces sind heute schon relativ komplex,
weil sie eben sehr viele Ereignisse und sehr viele Informationen darstellen müssen.
und wir sind weit gekommen mit Fenstern und Rahmen und 3D-Effekten und all diesen
ganzen Versuchen in irgendeiner Form dem Auge schnell klarzumachen, was passiert.
Aber generell finde ich, sind so Animationen eine gute Idee und seitdem irgendwie
Fenster nicht einfach nur verschwinden, wenn man sie schließt,
sondern sie eben auch mit einer Bewegung verschwinden,
ist eine Menge geholfen, weil man einfach unterbewusst registriert, was passiert.
Ja, wenn die Animationen, wenn
die die Interaktion unterstützen und nicht einfach nur Spielkram sind.
Genau, aber ich finde, dass diese, so wie es jetzt mit dem iOS,
also wie es auf dem iPhone ist, finde ich gut.
Also ich mag das.
Also ich war selber ein bisschen überrascht, dass ich es mag, aber ich mag es.
Das Einzige, was mich ein bisschen gewundert hat, ist, dass man jetzt ja vorne
und hinten von Apple gezwungen wird, die neue Icons zu basteln,
die ja dann auch in mehreren Ebenen aufgebaut sind, damit man sie von verschiedenen Seiten sehen kann.
Ja, allerdings man sieht das gar nicht irgendwo.
Also ich hätte jetzt erwartet, dass wenn du das iPhone kippst,
du hast ja vorher schon dieses Ding gehabt, dass wenn du das iPhone hin und
her bewegst, dass sich die Icons vor dem Hintergrund bewegen und ich hätte jetzt erwartet,
dass die verschiedenen Ebenen eines Icons sich auch mitbewegen,
wie jetzt beispielsweise irgendwie beim Apple TV oder bei der Vision oder so.
Aber irgendwie tun sie es nicht.
Also ich verstehe es nicht. Aber gut, vielleicht.
Egal.
Benutzt ihr eigentlich diese monochromen Icons? Die gibt es ja jetzt schon eine Weile.
Ich habe es einmal versucht und habe gemerkt, dass ich so dermaßen Icons nach
Farbe erkenne. Ja, also viel, viel mehr als nach Form.
Manchmal ist irgendeine Firma so schlau und denkt sich, ach so ein neues Icon
wäre doch geil und ich finde die App nicht wieder, weil das Icon hat jetzt eine
andere Farbe und dann verschwindet es einfach, weil der Schlüsselreiz fehlt,
der mich dazu animiert, zu sagen, okay, das ist die App, die du haben willst. Keine Ahnung.
Und am besten weißt du auch gar nicht mehr, wie die App heißt und dann findest
du sie nicht mehr auf deinem Telefon.
Und dann gibt es wiederum Apps, die kennst du nur namen nach und würdest sie
aber als Icon nicht finden.
Also keine Ahnung. Nee, also ich bin komplett lost, wenn ich da diesen Monochrom-Modus
der Icons anschalte. Das hat überhaupt gar keinen Sinn für mich.
Geht mir auch so. Ich bin ja froh, dass ich nicht der Einzige bin.
Da bist du nicht der Einzige. Da haben wir ja Mehrheitsmeinung,
weil ich kann damit auch nichts anfangen. Aber es gibt Leute, die machen das.
Es gibt auch Leute, die investieren extrem viel Zeit oder haben das früher schon
getan, alle ihre Icons nach Farbe zu sortieren.
Dann hast du so einen roten Screen, einen grünen Screen und so weiter.
Ja gut, aber so viel ADHS habe ich dann auch wiederum nicht, dass ich das tun würde.
Oder zu viel.
Oder zu viel oder zu wenig Autismus, ich weiß es nicht.
Also nee, ich habe schon so dieses Ding, dass ich mich fürchterlich ärgere,
wenn sich die Icons mal verschieben aus irgendeinem Grund.
Aber nee, also sortieren.
Aber es ist ja immer so, diese ganzen offensichtlichen Features,
die die neuen Betriebssysteme mit sich bringen, da denkt man sich so,
ja, ob es das jetzt gebraucht hätte und so, aber dann so über die Wochen findet
man ja dann überhaupt erstmal die tatsächlichen Änderungen so unter der Haube raus.
Ich bin da noch nicht sehr weit gekommen, aber ein Feature muss ich mal kurz
erwähnen und zwar, es gibt ja seit längerem schon die Möglichkeit mit FileVault
seine Festplätze zu verschlüsseln.
Längerem ist gut, das sind glaube ich schon 20 Jahre, wenn nicht noch mehr.
Naja, so lange gibt es ja Mac OS X überhaupt erst.
Ja, aber das war relativ früh schon dabei, 10.4 oder so? Oder erinnere ich mich
falsch? Egal, auf jeden Fall, es gibt es lange.
Auf jeden Fall, solange es das schon gibt, gibt es halt ein generelles Problem,
nämlich wenn dein Rechner neu startet, möchte er dann halt auch Passwort haben,
um überhaupt erstmal zu booten.
Und wenn du sozusagen in irgendeiner Form...
Also zu Recht, muss ich sagen.
Ja, absolut hast du recht.
Das ist bloß dann so ein bisschen schwierig, wenn du deinen Computer so headless
betreibst, also ohne, dass da irgendwie jetzt eine Tastatur und ein Bildschirm
dran angeschlossen ist.
Kopflos bezieht sich jetzt nicht auf den User.
Nein, sondern bezieht sich auf, dass du keinen Bildschirm hast.
Weil du dich dann normalerweise nur remote drauf einloggst, aber du möchtest
halt trotzdem unter Umständen dieses Feature haben, dann kannst du deine Kiste halt nicht irgendwie,
booten oder nicht auch gerade so mit ja, nach Stromverbrauch,
nach Stromverlust bootet dich automatisch und so, was machst du dann?
So, dann ist es mal ein bisschen lästig. Geht schon, aber ist halt lästig.
Mit macOS 26 gibt es jetzt die Möglichkeit, das mit SSH zu machen.
Du kannst, wenn die Kiste quasi noch nicht wirklich gebootet ist,
läuft bereits auf den konfigurierten Netzwerkschnittstellen ein SSH-Server und
du kannst dich mit SSH dahin verbinden und dann quasi dein Login machen.
Wirst dann aber natürlich auch gleich rausgeschmissen, also du bist dann nicht
als User eingeloggt, sondern dann bootet er eigentlich erst,
aber du kannst quasi nicht nur über die Tastatur über USB oder Bluetooth jetzt
dein Passwort eingeben, sondern du kannst es halt auch über Netz machen, einfach mit SSH.
Hat der einen MDNS-Responder an Bord?
Ja, das geht dann schon auch. Da haben sie schon drauf geachtet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es nur mir so geht, aber ich finde MDNS-Responder ist doch
so eigentlich Basic-Werkzeug, das ein Betriebssystem immer dabei haben sollte, oder?
Ja.
Ja, also was du meinst ist, dass ein Rechner auf .local-Adressanfragen reagiert.
ja, selbstverständlich sollten das alle haben und zwar schon seit langem,
aber das haben halt eigentlich nur so richtig, nur so Macs und wenn du halt auf deinem FreeBSD.
Hat das auch.
FreeBSD hat es jetzt auch?
Ja.
Okay, gut, bei Linux halt, wenn du da so ein Avahi rein konfiguriert hast,
aber oft halt auch irgendwie nicht.
Meine Erfahrung zumindest, mag es sich geändert haben, don't add me.
Nerves macht es ja nicht.
Ich will das Thema jetzt nicht zu sehr nach vorne ziehen, aber ich hab ich hab
gerade erst einen Linux, aus Gründen einen Linux installiert.
Und?
Ja, da ist kein MDNS-Responder dabei.
Da musst du rein konfigurieren.
Ja, aber das kostet irgendwie extra. Also ich meine, klar, mit AI-Hilfe habe
ich das dann auch hingekriegt, aber das war dann mindestens eine Viertelstunde,
die mich das gekostet hat, dann in den AWAHI ordentlich hinzukriegen.
Nur um mich auf der Kiste mit SSH anzumelden.
Ja, aber eine Fritzbox macht das ja bis heute noch nicht.
Na gut. Fritzbox macht einige Sachen merkwürdig.
Ja, die macht nicht alles merkwürdig, aber das hat mich schon immer genervt,
dass du bei einer Fritzbox kein, also zwei Sachen nerven mich.
Erstens, dass sie kein Gerät.local machen.
Also den MDN Rest Responder?
Genau. Also dass das erstmal schon mal nicht geht. Dafür hijacken sie ja die
.box, Top-Level-Domain, die es ja mittlerweile auch in echt gibt.
Was auch eine ganz schlechte Idee ist. Also das hat auch schon zu interessanten
Nebenwirkungen geführt. Ja, das hat auch schon zu Nebenwirkungen geführt und so weiter.
Weil dann irgendwie die Domänen, mittlerweile haben sie die gekauft sozusagen,
die fritz.box-Domänen.
Aber die hatte halt sich jemand anders unter den Nagel gerissen und dann standen
sie halt doof da, weil das dann doch abgefischt wurde.
Aber bitteschön. Was die sich nicht vorstellen können ist, dass man in einem
Netzwerk zwei Fritzboxen hat.
Erinnere mich nicht dran.
Ja, aber das ist einfach, ich meine, hallo, man zieht halt noch so eine alte
Fritzbox aus der Schublade, schließt die als Netz an und dann heißen die beide Fritz.box.
Wirklich, es kann doch nicht so schwer sein.
Obwohl, du kannst es umkonfigurieren, dass sie sich anders meldet.
Was?
Aber das musst du natürlich irgendwie tun, bevor du dann die zweite an den Start
kriegst, sonst hast du das Problem.
Wie, wann kann das, dass sie sich anders melden?
Ich glaube, das kann man.
Ne, man kann keinen Namen, also wenn sie das jetzt im letzten Jahr hinzugefügt
haben, dann ist es mir nicht aufgefallen, aber man kann dem keinen Namen geben,
wo er sich dann unter Punktlocal meldet.
Also du kannst ihm irgendeinen Namen geben, der aber sich nicht im Netzwerk manifestiert.
Also irgendwie ging das mit den zwei Boxen. Ich habe das irgendwann mal konfiguriert.
Das war aber auch alles sehr, sehr weird.
Und ich glaube, man kann sich dann auf die zweite nur über die erste anmelden
oder so. Es ist auch ganz, ganz komisch.
Also, na gut.
Ich muss mich mal hier mal wieder anmelden. Ich habe mich lange schon nicht
mehr in meiner Fritzbox angemeldet. Jetzt mache ich das mal.
Jetzt habe ich erstmal hier SSL-Problematik.
Also du kannst dein Ding meinen Namen.
Wenn die Live-Hörer jetzt gleich nichts mehr hören.
Dann wisst ihr es.
Genau. Was meintest du, Luca?
Einmal neu starten. Also ich sehe das, ich bin auf meiner Fritzbox drauf,
ich kann hier einen Namen vergeben.
Ja, aber der...
Da steht nicht so genau drin, was für Auswirkungen das hat.
Das bedeutet auf jeden Fall nicht, dass es danach Name.local in deinem Netz
gibt. Du kannst das ja gerne mal prüfen.
Wir veranschieden uns jetzt von unserem remote zugeschalteten Gast.
Ja.
Ja, nee, gut, ja. Nee, also MDNS Responder ist ja jetzt auch keine brandneue Technologie.
Das kann man im Jahr 2025 schon mal als Standard irgendwie in seinem Betriebssystem
tun. Das ist schon richtig.
Ja, den Avahi-Pain kenne ich auch, dass man sich dann fragt,
ich muss das erstmal installieren.
Dann nochmal gucken, wie konfiguriert man das? ist es tatsächlich,
glaube ich, sogar im Kernel oder irgendwas inzwischen und das FreeBSD kommt
hoch mit einem per MDNS Responder announceten SSH.
Ja, wie man das halt macht. Ich meine, das ist doch einfach, ich glaube, das ist,
weißt du, ich glaube, Linux, jetzt werden sie gleich wieder alle auf mich einhauen,
weil ich immer so auf Linux einhaue, aber das ist auch ein kulturelles Problem.
Das ist ja so ein Not-Invented-Here-Syndrom. Also dieses Bonjour,
das ist ja von Apple, das muss böse sein.
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich ist es nicht unter der GNU-Lizenz und dann kann man
es natürlich nicht verwenden.
Ach, schnickschnack.
Naja, keine Ahnung. Also ich habe halt so einen Ubuntu-Server installiert und
du musst bei der Konfiguration, wenn du das installiert hast,
da drauf dringen, dass er bitteschön IPv6 verwendet.
Der schaltet das nicht von alleine an, sondern du musst ihm sagen,
ja natürlich will ich nicht nur IPv4, sondern auch IPv6 haben.
In der Standardkonfiguration im Jahre 2025, ich sag's nochmal,
also das ist irgendwie, ich war doch ein bisschen schockiert.
Ich bitte dich, das ist doch erst 1998 spezifiziert worden.
Nicht so schnell.
Nee, nicht so schnell. Irgendwie aber dann immer rumjammern,
dass sie nicht auf den Desktop kommen, wenn sie solche Sachen schon nicht hinkriegen. Also wirklich.
Lass uns bei Apple bleiben. Viel fällt mir jetzt nicht mehr zu ein.
Ist euch noch irgendwas Schönes aufgefallen, was ganz toll ist?
Nee, also sagen wir mal so, ich fand es überraschend schmerzlos,
dieses Betriebssystem zu installieren und normalerweise sind ja so größere Änderungen
am Design, führen ja gerne mal dazu,
dass Dinge entweder super hässlich aussehen oder teilweise gar nicht funktionieren
und das war mir jetzt so nicht untergekommen. Also das fand ich schon,
erstaunlich. Also da haben wir schon auch schlechtere Beta-Versionen gesehen.
Also selbst die Beta 1, die habe ich ja, oder Beta 2 oder so,
die habe ich ja direkt auf meinen Mac Mini gepackt und der so war was.
Es war schon sehr langsam in dieser Beta-Phase, aber das ist ja auch keine Überraschung.
M4 Mac Mini merkt man es dann vielleicht nicht so sehr.
Also ich habe es schon gemerkt, dass sie so kurz vor Release erst der Performance-Schraube
wieder ein bisschen gedreht haben und es ist auch noch einiges zu gehen,
also ich muss jetzt hier meinen Rechner alle zwei Tage mal neu booten, weil der Safari hängt.
Und sich auch mit Ausloggen und so weiter nicht zufrieden gibt.
Also da ist schon noch hier einiges im Argen.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, ich werde mal diese Punkt 1 Beta installieren. Naja.
Wir stellen fest, wir haben eigentlich gar keine richtige Ahnung,
was alles Tolles und Neues und wir werden das beobachten.
Aber am Ende haben sie es doch irgendwie hinbekommen,
diese Betriebssysteme zu releasen. Und ich meine, mal ehrlich,
sie releasen jetzt mittlerweile gleichzeitig am selben Tag,
iOS, iPadOS, WatchOS, MacOS und tvOS und habe ich noch was vergessen?
VisionOS vielleicht?
Ach ja, genau, VisionOS, genau. Und im Prinzip ja auch ihr, ich weiß nicht,
was ihr auf den Homepods, wie das heißt.
Das heißt, glaube ich.
Auch HomeOS oder HomePodOS oder keine Ahnung.
Es ist, glaube ich, auch ein sehr abgespecktes iOS.
Ich habe auch, ehrlich gesagt, gar keinen Podcast.
Naja, man muss jetzt natürlich iPadOS. Ja, aber ich finde das bemerkenswert.
Dass sie das sozusagen schaffen, da so einen parallelen Rollout zu machen und
mehr oder weniger auf die Kette zu bekommen mit so vielen Geräten.
Sagen wir mal so, dass sie es endlich geschafft haben, diesen ganzen Scheiß
mal, diesen Zoo mal einzufangen und,
ich finde ja, also gut, da hatten wir ja schon drüber geredet,
dass das iPad jetzt doch ein sehr, sehr ähnliches,
Benutzungskonzept hat wie das macOS, das fand ich schon auch sehr spannend.
Also sie haben da wirklich viel rübergenommen und das Zusammenwachsen wird wahrscheinlich,
ich weiß nicht wie nahtlos das dann irgendwann sein wird, aber ich hoffe mal.
Ich hoffe mal, ich hoffe mal.
Gut.
Wollen wir ein bisschen über AI reden?
Müssen wir?
Ja. Was heißt müssen? Wir müssen eigentlich gar nichts hier.
Aber man könnte ja mal drüber reden.
Na gut.
Und zwar, weil ich das ganz interessant fand, was OpenAI geblockt hat über ihre Halluzination.
Habt ihr das auch gesehen?
Nein.
Why Language Models Hallucinate? Und das ist ganz interessant.
Es gibt da ein Paper und das Paper erklären sie auch in so einem Blogpost,
in so etwas weniger Paper-Sprache.
Und sagen wir mal so, Ihnen ist das auch aufgefallen.
Ihnen ist aufgefallen.
Ihnen ist aufgefallen,
dass Hallucination ein Ding ist. Und naja,
ist nicht so, dass sie da jetzt quasi auf ihrem Arsch sitzen geblieben sind,
sondern haben da weiter geforscht und haben da eine interessante Erkenntnis,
die irgendwie banal klingt,
aber die man ja auch erstmal erforschen muss.
Und ja, sie haben sich das also mal genauer angeschaut, wo kommen eigentlich
die falschen Antworten her.
Und ihnen ist aufgefallen bei ihren Tests, dass falsche Antworten selbst dann
kommen, wenn sie Trainingsmaterial verwenden, was absolut korrekt ist.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, mit welchem Trainingsmaterial Sie das jetzt sichergestellt haben.
Mit welcher Sicherheit Sie sagen, dass das absolut korrekt ist?
Genau, naja, aber das war, sagen wir mal, Ihre Feststellung.
Das kann sein, dass das im Paper erwähnt ist.
Ich habe das Paper nicht komplett gelesen, ich habe mir diesen Blogpost durchgelesen.
Noch ein paar Interpretationen dritter dazu.
Aber das war jetzt erstmal eine der Feststellungen.
Und es gibt ja auch ein sehr unterschiedliches Verhalten. Also diese Halluzinationen
zum Beispiel sind ja zum Beispiel in der Sprache selbst nicht drin.
Also der fängt ja nicht an, sich neue Worte einfallen zu lassen,
sondern die Sprache, mit der eine LLM mit dir so korrespondiert und übersetzt,
das funktioniert ja wirklich sehr gut.
Oder sagen wir mal, die Zeiten, wo sie sich noch Worte ausgedacht haben, sind lange hinter uns.
Ich habe das gar nicht erlebt. Das muss dann, wenn noch so GPT-3 vielleicht Zeiten gewesen sein.
GPT-2.
Und seit 3 ist es eigentlich, ist das mit der Sprache eigentlich durch das Thema.
War aber auch lustig. Also ich fand das immer sehr unterhaltsam,
wenn da so total bizarre Halluzinationen rauskamen.
Jetzt was die Sprache selber betrifft.
Ja.
Ja, okay, na klar. Aber das ist halt ein Problem, was so jetzt eigentlich gar nicht auftritt,
sondern die Sprache passt, was man jetzt sagen wir mal von einem System,
was sich Large Language Model nennt, ja auch in gewisser Hinsicht erwarten würde.
Und der Grund dafür ist einfach schlicht der, dass die Muster in den Trainingsdaten,
die diese Sprache kodieren, so vielfältig sind.
Also du hast in deinem ganzen Trainingsmaterial, alles ist Sprache.
Also jede Nuance, jedes Wort, was irgendwie zum Einsatz kommt in irgendeiner
Sprache, ist vielfältig vorhanden in tausend Kombinationen mit allen anderen Worten drin.
Sprich, es gibt so viel Material, aus dem gelernt werden kann,
dass man feststellen kann, Sprache funktioniert dann einfach auch.
Also da wird nicht mehr halluziniert, sondern da gibt es eigentlich nur noch richtige Antworten.
Allerdings ist das halt bei Fakten jetzt nicht so und wir haben alle schon mal
unseren Namen eingegeben und gefragt, was ist mein Geburtsdatum und auch wenn
das vielleicht irgendwo im Internet steht,
hat einfach ein LLM da keinerlei Möglichkeiten das zu machen.
Die einzige Möglichkeit, die die LLMs bisher hatten, ist halt so Tool-Use, dass du sagst, ja okay,
du weißt, wie du jetzt eine Wikipedia-API bedienen kannst und wenn du jetzt
fragst, wann hat denn Tim Britlaff Geburtstag, dann kannst du ja theoretisch
Wikipedia als Tool benutzen und dann eben eine wahre Antwort quasi aus Wikidata rausholen.
rausholen, nur so als Beispiel, das machen sie ja so konkret nicht,
aber das wäre quasi die einzige Möglichkeit, ein Faktum zu produzieren,
was zweifelsfrei aus einer, in Anführungsstrichen, wahren Quelle kommt.
Aber in den Trainingsdaten sind diese Dinge ja selten vertreten.
Also du hast dann vielleicht ein oder zwei Instanzen irgendwo im ganzen Internet,
wo so eine Information überhaupt vorliegt, aber du hast halt nicht im Ansatz
diese Massen von Variationen, die immer wieder einen Fakt bestätigen.
Andererseits kannst du natürlich jetzt so etwas wie, wie funktioniert das Universum,
die Physik, die Chemie etc.
Auch da hast du sehr, sehr, sehr viele Daten, die diese Fakten belegen.
Deswegen sind dann, sagen wir mal, die Kernaussagen, die man aus so einem LLM
herausziehen kann, relativ fundiert.
Da magst du jetzt im letzten Detail nicht unbedingt stimmen,
aber du kannst ja irgendwie relativ okay Strom erklären lassen.
Sagen wir es mal so, weil da liegt halt auch entsprechend viel vor.
Naja und die gängige
Methode Trainingsmodelle oder überhaupt Modelle richtig zu machen ist ja nach
der primären Trainingsphase nochmal so ein Post-Refinement zu fahren mit eben so Wahrheitstests.
mit, ja, gib mir mal die richtige Antwort und wenn du mir die richtige Antwort
gibst, dann wirst du belohnt.
Und das führt ja durchaus dazu, dass diese Modelle sich verbessern,
Aber man hat halt jetzt festgestellt in diesem Paper,
dass diese Methode mit so Multiple-Choice-Tests dazu führt, dass das System
quasi anfängt, wie so ein richtiger Student zu cheaten.
Weil das System quasi merkt, ich weiß zwar hier auf diese Frage nicht die Antwort,
ich bin mir hier nicht sicher, ich habe dieses Faktum nicht da,
aber für eine falsche Antwort werde ich ja bestraft.
Aber ich kann aber auch genauso gut mir irgendwas einfallen lassen,
random, irgendwas herbeihalluzinieren und es kann dann mit einer bestimmten
Wahrscheinlichkeit sein, dass ich das Richtige herausfinde und dann erhalte
ich einen höheren Score,
als wenn ich sage, dass ich das nicht weiß.
Das erinnert mich an einige Gespräche, die ich mit Bewerbern hatte.
Ja, das ist einfach ein menschliches Verhalten.
Du bist in so einem Stress und generell würde ich auch sagen,
ist das in unserer Kultur ja so, dass es nicht hoch dir angerechnet wird,
wenn du sagst, dass du was nicht weißt.
Es gibt glaube ich Kulturen, wo das schlimmer ist.
Ja, mag sein, aber generell wir bewerten die Leute nach, was weißt du denn?
Und wenn du was weißt, dann ist es geil und wenn du sagst, weiß ich nicht,
dann ist es halt so höhöhö, du hast ja keine Ahnung.
Dabei ist aber genau das eben so eine Qualität. Und.
Ja, nee, erzähl weiter Tim.
Genau, so und jetzt sagen sie quasi in diesem Paper, Training von einem LLM
muss das I don't know belohnen.
Also man muss quasi seine Trainingsmodelle so umbauen, dass in diesem Post-Training
ein I don't know quasi nicht so negativ durchschlägt wie Raten.
Weil damit, diese Halluzinationen sind sozusagen etwas, was durch eine falsche
Bewertungsstrategie hervorgerufen wird.
Oder wie es mal ein Messebesucher zu mir am Messestand gesagt hat,
I prefer honesty over bullshit.
Ja, genau. Und das war derzeit in diesen Trainingsmodellen einfach oder in diesen
Trainingsmethoden nicht drin, weil wenn du das I don't know nicht belohnst,
dann sucht sich die AI quasi automatisch so einen Schummelweg,
weil einfach der Zufall mehr Wert hat.
Aber eine richtige Antwort muss ja immer noch mehr besser belohnt werden,
sonst sagt das Ding immer I don't know.
Ne, das ist klar, das ist richtig, aber es wird halt dann nicht bestraft.
Dass man es nicht weiß.
Und da haben sie wohl deutlich bessere Ergebnisse erzielt.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher,
wie gut die Ergebnisse waren, aber das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal so, die Strategie.
und sie erwarten wohl, dass sich damit diese Halluzinationsrate reduzieren lässt,
vielleicht sogar auch komplett in den Griff bekommen lässt.
Bei ChatGPT5 sei das wohl schon auch mit drin.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das generell für alles, also in welchem Maße oder ob das
sozusagen noch ein Refinement ist.
Dafür müsstest du doch überhaupt erstmal Fakten strukturiert haben,
oder? Um das so trainieren zu können.
Ja klar, aber das ist ja Teil dieses Post-Trainings, dass man halt einfach diese
Systeme auf bestimmte Known-Facts hin abklopft und dadurch quasi härtet.
Also ich habe ja gerade mal ausprobiert und habe ChatGPT gefragt,
was kannst du mir über meinen Namen sagen?
Und dann sagt er tatsächlich, ich kann nichts Verlässliches über eine konkrete Person namens finden.
Keine Birographie, keine öffentliche Person dieses Namens taucht in seriösen Quellen auf.
Aha.
Zumindest nicht in meinen zugänglichen Literatur- oder Datenbanken.
Ja, und das ist natürlich eine sehr viel bessere Ausgabe als ein,
ja, Roddy ist ein schottischer Gynäkologe, der irgendwie besonders gut Golf spielen kann.
Ja, nein.
Impliziert aber auch, dass die Freakshow nicht seriös ist.
Oder ich da nicht unter meinem richtigen Namen gelistet werde.
Es gibt ja nicht viel Fakten zu dir.
Naja, ich habe meinen tatsächlichen Namen genannt.
Achso, der steht da gar nicht.
Ja, eben.
Von daher passt das schon so. Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen,
bei OpenAI ist jetzt alles supi, aber ich fand einfach diese Erkenntnis sehr interessant,
dass es unter Umständen hier einen Ansatz gibt,
der zumindest diese Halluzinationen im Faktenbereich reduzieren kann und dazu
führen kann, dass wir eben sehr viel mehr so I don't know und weiß nicht,
kann ich dir nicht weiterhelfen,
Antworten bekommen. Weil das ist ja auch okay.
Dann weiß man zumindest, woran man ist und man wird eben nicht so ohne weiteres
zumindest in die falsche Richtung geführt.
Ich glaube ja ohnehin, dass all das, worüber wir uns derzeit noch so aufregen mit diesem AI-Kram,
unter Umständen mit noch etwas mehr Research in den nächsten Jahren ganz schnell
nicht mehr so das Problem sein wird.
Also die Wahrnehmung ist natürlich derzeit so, aber das hat,
glaube ich, gar nicht mal so eine hohe Halbwertszeit.
Ja gut, also die Entwicklung ist rasant gegangen. Es sieht nicht danach aus,
als würde sie sich irgendwie verlangsamen.
Nee, zumindest nicht in absehbarer Zeit.
Also man kann zusammenfassend, man kann sagen, Nvidia geht nicht so schnell pleite.
Das auch nicht. Wer Aktien gekauft hat, als es diesen Dip gab,
hat durchaus, glaube ich,
Punkte machen können.
Tja, ich bin kein Spekulant.
Kleine lustige Nebengeschichte noch, die hier vielleicht ganz gut reinpasst.
Und zwar gibt es eine,
Arbeitsgruppe bei Tencent. Tencent ist der Produzent von, nicht TikTok,
sondern von WeChat, glaube ich.
Ja, die haben relativ viele Finger in Dingen.
Unter anderem gehört denen jetzt auch ein größerer Teil von Ubisoft,
wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe.
Genau. Tencent, QQ und WeChat kommen von Tencent.
Und es bin nicht überraschend, dass ja die Chinesen auch ganz gut unterwegs
sind, so in der AI-Forschung, haben wir ja schon gesehen, so DeepSeek und so weiter.
Und was die mal gemacht haben, ist, die haben einen sogenannten Autocode-Benchmark gefahren.
Also sie haben quasi alle erdenklichen Programmiersprachen genommen und den...
gängigen Modellen entsprechende Programmieraufgaben, also sozusagen dieselbe
Programmieraufgabe in allen möglichen Sprachen über alle möglichen Modelle gefahren.
Also sie haben quasi getestet, wie gut lässt sich eine bestimmte Aufgabe mit
einem LLM in einer bestimmten Programmiersprache lösen.
Und haben sich dann sozusagen das Ergebnis angeschaut und nach bestimmten Kriterien
bewertet, die ich mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt im Detail nicht angeschaut habe.
Und dort kamen halt so LLMs wie Opus, also Clode, Opus 4, Clode Sonnet 4,
OpenAI O3 High, O4 Mini, dann dieses Grog 4 von den Idioten, DeepSeek R1.
Und dann so Quen von Alibaba ist das, glaube ich, das Modell.
Und dann noch ein paar Modelle, die ich nicht kenne. Ernie, X1,
GLM und Seed kenne ich nicht.
Ah ja, und Gemini 2.5 Pro auch noch.
Also Google OpenAI, Anthropic und Alibaba sind hier vertreten.
Ah ne, und noch ein paar mehr. Was haben wir hier noch?
Seed Coder, Kimi, also ein paar Sachen, die mir jetzt ehrlich gesagt, nichts sagen.
GPT-4.1, GPT-4.0 kam auch noch zum Einsatz.
Genau, OpenCola. Also eine ganze Batterie, so 30 verschiedene Dinger.
Und diese Aufgaben haben sie dann mit einer ganzen Reihe von Programmiersprachen
gemacht, nämlich Python, C++, Java, JavaScript, Go,
Shell, C Sharp, also Shell ist C-Sharp, Dart,
Alex hier auch, Julia, Kotlin, Perl, PHP, Racket, das ist glaube ich so eine neue Lisp-Variante.
Das ist ein Scheme, genau.
Genau, R, diese Statistiksprache, Ruby, Rust, Scala, Swift und Typescript.
Also wirklich mal so richtig in die Vollen gegangen.
Und dann haben sie eben diese Ergebnisse bewertet und dem so ein Score verpasst.
Also wie sie jetzt auf diesen Score gekommen sind, kann ich denen jetzt nicht sagen.
Ja, ist ja ein ganz interessanter Ansatz.
Was würdet ihr meinen, welche Programmiersprache sich am besten hat schreiben
lassen mit diesen ganzen LLMs?
Ich kenne das Ergebnis ja schon. Ich lasse mal Roddy raten.
Man würde ja vermuten, dass die Programmiersprachen, die am meisten Trainingsdaten
haben, die in die Modelle geflossen sind, oder zumindest gute Trainingsdaten,
dass die die Nase vorne haben.
das ist das eine das zweite ist, ich weiß nicht wie die Modelle trainiert werden,
aber ich könnte mir vorstellen dass Compiler basierte Sprachen einen Vorteil
haben weil sie dadurch dass der Compiler den Code ja nochmal checkt dem Modell
in der Lernphase auf die Finger klopfen kann,
so nach der Art das kompiliert nicht, was du mir hier gegeben hast.
Ja, weil das ist so ein Refining Prozess quasi ja noch mit ein quasi fest eingebaut ist.
Aber ja nicht nur in der Lernphase, auch in der Coding-Phase, was das Modell ja macht.
Ansonsten, keine Ahnung, schwer zu sagen, ob es jetzt Programmiersprachen gibt, die da...
Besser abschneiden oder nicht?
Ja, ich denke, diese These, dass die Programmiersprache vor allem von seiner
Verbreitung profitiert, weil es ja dann sozusagen viel davon gibt, steht es im Raum.
Es kommt natürlich darauf an. Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass es Programmiersprachen
gibt, wo, sagen wir mal so, die ist zwar sehr verbreitet,
aber die entsprechenden Webseiten, wo Leute diskutieren, halt voll ist von Code,
über den diskutiert wird, der halt nicht funktioniert und sie nur immer die
ganze Zeit fragen, wie kriege ich denn die Scheiße an Lauf?
und wenn die Modelle diesen Code mitlernen, lernen sie ja jetzt nicht unbedingt guten Code.
Das wird ja auf ziemlich vielen Code im Internet zutreffen, denke ich.
Ja, naja, ich weiß ja nicht, wie die ihre Modelle trainieren.
Ich auch nicht, aber es gibt ziemlich viel schlechten Code da draußen.
Ja. Also auf jeden Fall haben die
das jetzt gemacht und haben halt eine entsprechende Tabelle rausgehauen,
wo sie dann alle Sprachen kombinieren und die mit Abstand am besten zu erzeugende Sprache,
also die Sprache, die quasi die besten Ergebnisse nach ihrem Scoring bekommen hat,
ist Elixir.
C-Sharp, wenn ich die Tabelle richtig interpretiere, ist aber auch relativ weit vorne.
Ja, also es gibt da einige Überraschungen und vor allem das,
was man so erwarten würde wie Python, ist relativ schlecht.
Naja gut, aber meine Theorie mit kompilierten Sprachen und quasi einer kurzen
Feedback-Loop, ob das was da ausgespuckt wird, auch was taugt,
da sind natürlich alle interpretierten Sprachen sofort raus.
Ja, aber C++ ist genauso schlecht.
Äh, C++?
Also C++ und Python, das nimmt sich nicht viel. Also das ist so alles in derselben Kategorie.
Java ist ein bisschen besser als C++.
Nee, C++ ist doch deutlich besser als Python.
Naja, das ist alles so im 30-40er-Bereich teilweise.
Hier Current Upper Bound, wo guckst du denn danach?
Ich gucke in dem letzten Link, den ich gerade veröffentlicht habe. im Slack.
Das ist dann sozusagen diese Übersicht. Siehst du das?
Achso, das ist Performance Upabout.
Ja, ich werfe dir das mal hier auf unseren Beamer.
Und da sieht man das.
Also ist so. Also C++ ist da nicht besonders gut.
Java auch nur unwesentlich besser. Auch JavaScript ziemlich schlecht.
auch Go, also.
Aber C++ ist hier bei 74 ist Average, also Python ist unter Average.
Das ist aber auch der Upper Bound, also da wird angezeigt, wie oft die das durchgeführt
haben und was dann der höchste Score jeweils war und darunter ist dann,
wenn ich das richtig interpretiere, der Average Score.
Aber es gibt den Medien, naja gut, oh Gott, PHP ist ja das ist ja ein das ist ein Trainwreck Ja.
Also was sich hier eigentlich herauslesen lässt ist, dass das ist jetzt meine
Interpretation, also bestimmte Sprachen die, sagen wir mal nicht,
Wie soll ich das ausdrücken? Also Sprachen, in denen man irgendwie so alles
mögliche schreiben kann und wo es irgendwie keinen klaren Style gibt,
die haben es ja auf jeden Fall schwerer als Sprachen, die irgendwie klarer definiert sind.
So würde ich es mal so ein bisschen herauslesen.
Naja gut, aber ich kenne jetzt auch niemanden, der großer Fan von C++ ist.
Also das ist eine Sprache, die ist ja schon tot geboren.
Ja, C++ ist kompliziert. Es gibt Leute, du wirst natürlich in jeder Sprache
Leute finden, die die Sprache jetzt total in all ihren Details kennen.
Plus, das ist so eine Sprache, die haben ja 25 Jahre von der Erfindung gebraucht,
das überhaupt zu standardisieren.
Also das ist ja die Sprache für den ersten Standard.
Ja, und sie wird immer noch weiter, also das stellt mich, ja,
das ist generell so ein bisschen auch so ein Problem bei vielen Programmiersprachen,
du hast halt dann am laufenden Meter eine neue Version, ja, und irgendwann weißt
du halt auch überhaupt nicht mehr, was es ist, also ich meine,
warum dauert denn das so lange, konnte die Sprache denn nicht schon vorher gut
sein, also die müssen alle permanent gepatcht und erweitert werden und es wird
nichts wirklich besser dabei.
Was mich wundert ist, dass Go so scheiße abschneidet.
Also eigentlich wundert es mich nicht, aber da hätte ich eigentlich mehr erwartet.
Im direkten Vergleich ist Dart sogar Dart besser.
Also Kotlin ist überraschend gut.
Ja, ich hätte es jetzt gerne mal hier in der Reihenfolge, ich kann das jetzt
hier auch selber nur machen, aber generell, also wir blicken jetzt hier auf Score-Werte,
das niedrigste ist PHP mit 42,8.
Dann hast du so einen 60er-Block, da ist dann Rust, ich gucke auf diesen Upper Bound.
Der Upper Bound, da steht über 52,8. Genau.
Dann hast du so im 60er-Bereich hast du so TypeScript.
Rust,
Go am oberen Ende, Python.
JavaScript ist noch unter 60.
Also wundert uns auch nicht, aber...
Ja, weil ich meine vom Trainingsmaterial her, es gibt halt viel Code,
aber es gibt halt auch viel schlechten Code.
Und vor allem die Sprache ist halt einfach nicht besonders stringent definiert.
Also du kannst da viel falsch machen und das ist halt so ein Problem.
Teufel tun hier, JavaScript zu verteidigen.
Genau, so und was führt halt hier irgendwie an, ich gucke gerade mal,
was ist denn im 80er Bereich, da hast du irgendwie so C-Sharp und Kotlin,
so diesen Racket, genau, also dieses Lisp.
Racket kenne ich gar nicht, was ist das?
Das ist so eine moderneres Scheme-Variante, das ist irgendwie so ein vor kurzem
sehr populär gewordene Lisp-Variante, ich weiß nicht so ganz genau, warum, weißt du das?
Das gibt es schon auch relativ lange.
Ja, aber es ist, hat es nicht erst, ich habe das nicht verfolgt.
Also nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Nee, verwechsel ich das vielleicht gerade mal. Ich gucke gerade mal,
von wann das ist. Racket, Premiere Sprache, tell me.
Erscheinungsjahr 2010. Das läuft bei mir unter neu.
Das ist modern, ja.
Ja, okay.
Also basiert zwar auf Lisp und Scheme und so weiter.
C haben sie gar nicht mehr drin. Das würde mich interessieren, wie da der Wert ist.
Ja, okay, gut. Also ist nicht so meine Syntax.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es das und schneidet hier noch relativ gut ab.
Und in dem 90er-Bereich hast du halt nur einen einzigen Vertreter und das ist Elixir mit 97,5.
Also Elixir ist hier sozusagen beyond everything else.
Das ist erstaunlich.
Das wäre jetzt aber mal interessant zu verstehen, woher das kommt.
Na gut, also ich könnte dir ein paar Thesen auf den Tisch, ich weiß nicht,
Luca, was denkst du darüber?
Also mein Gedanke dazu ist, also ich hatte auch den ähnlichen Gedankengang wie
du, Roddy, dass das ja irgendwie, also dass nicht nur die Menge der Trainingsdaten eine Rolle spielt,
sondern, also ich vermute, ein Faktor ist die Qualität an Trainingsdaten.
Mhm.
Da könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass die bei JavaScript und Python halt wirklich
krass runtergezogen wird, zum Teil.
PHP?
Ja, PHP wahrscheinlich auch. Also ich muss halt irgendwie annehmen,
ja, da wird wahrscheinlich auch von jedem, der gerade erst gestern angefangen
hat zu programmieren mit Python,
dessen Code auch im LLM verwurstet irgendwo.
Das ist eine Annahme, die ich habe.
da ist relativ viel Beginner-Code einfach von Leuten, die schlechten Codes schreiben,
weil sie es nicht anders gelernt haben bis jetzt die andere Sache,
die wahrscheinlich eine große Rolle spielt ist,
wie viele Footguns bieten dir diese Sprachen an da ist Footguns ein Feature
einer Sprache, was für mich eigentlich nur die Funktion hat,
dir in den Fuß zu schießen,
Auch da ein schönes Zitat.
Straustrup, der Name ist bekannt.
Piane Straustrup.
Genau, der hat in seinem eigenen Buch über C++ geschrieben.
It's easy to shoot yourself in the foot with C.
It's way harder to do it with C++, but if you do, the whole leg comes off.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich dem zustimmen würde.
Vorbei. Danke. Das war's.
Okay, aber jetzt sag doch nochmal, was du denkst.
Genau, C++ würde ich halt nämlich auch sagen, hat unfassbar viele Footguns.
Die Sprache gibt dir halt nicht nur genug Strick, um dich zu erhängen,
sondern auch den Schemel dazu und kickt den weg unter den Beinen.
Und liefert den Sarg und auch das ausgehobene Loch schon mit dazu.
Und bei Elixir, wenn du dir da, also die meiste Komplexität kommt meistens irgendwie
durch State, Shared State, Mutable State, das sind immer so die wirklich komplexen Dinge,
wo du dir dann auch in den Fuß schießt und bei einer Sprache,
bei Elixier, wo du keinen Mutable State hast in dem Sinne,
fallen diese ganzen Klassen von klassischen Fehlern weg.
Das ist meine Vermutung, dass das hier eine maßgebliche Rolle spielt.
Und PHP ist ja so eine Sprache, da ist ja korrekter Code eher Zufall, oder?
Ja, aber ich denke auch, dass es sehr viel damit zu tun hat.
Also diese Isolierung von Problemen. Du musst ja mal denken,
diese LLMs sind ja eigentlich nicht dafür gemacht.
Und die müssen nun sehr viele Dinge berücksichtigen, um laufenden Code zu machen.
Klar, du lernst erstmal aus existierendem Code und aus bestimmten Strategien.
Trotzdem muss ja dann der konkrete Algorithmus, den du erzeugst,
der muss, ja, der darf sich eben nicht in den Fuß schießen.
Und wenn du von vornherein ein System hast, was eben diese ganzen Fußschießmechanismen,
weitgehend gar nicht mehr hat und das ist ja im Prinzip das,
was Luca schon gesagt hat, also diese Shared State, du hast eine Gleichzeitigkeit.
Und du kämpfst um sozusagen einen Speicherbereich und Und wie willst du überprüfen,
wenn du nicht selber den Code ausführst sozusagen, dass es hier zu keinen Konflikten kommt.
Und das ist halt ja eigentlich genau eine der Kernthesen von Erlang gewesen
am Anfang. genau das ist das Problem und genau das wollen wir von vornherein verhindern.
Indem wir einfach sagen, es gibt Prozesse und alles ist voneinander getrennt
und keiner kann dem anderen irgendwie irgendwo hinschreiben und das mag hier eine Rolle spielen.
Eine andere Rolle, die glaube ich hier noch mit drin ist, ist die meisten Sprachen,
ich kann jetzt wirklich nicht für alle hier genannten Sprachen sprechen,
aber das gilt auf jeden Fall für sowas wie C, C++, Python, Java, JavaScript, Krypt.
Und auf jeden Fall auch Perl und PHP und wahrscheinlich auch Ruby.
Das sind so Sprachen, wo es unheimlich viele Möglichkeiten gibt,
dasselbe auf unterschiedliche Art und Weise auszudrücken.
Also wo du einfach so eine Vielzahl von Ansätzen hast, wie man es auch noch
schreiben kann, wie man es auch noch machen kann.
Teilweise eben auch so diese Multi-Paradigmen-Ansätze mit ja,
du kannst ja irgendwie total imperativ programmieren, aber du kannst halt auch
irgendwie was mit Objekten machen und dann haben wir aber auch noch so ein bisschen so,
ja Lambdas haben wir jetzt auch, also du bist so ein bisschen funktional,
von allem bist du so irgendwas, aber du bist eigentlich nichts wirklich.
Und das führt natürlich auch zu so einer Konfusion. Und da wundert es mich nicht,
dass jetzt Elixir gut abschneidet, weil bei Elixir ist es relativ klar, was es ist.
Und es gibt eigentlich kaum, klar, es gibt so ein bisschen Syntax-Schucker,
kannst du ein bisschen so schreiben, kannst du ein bisschen so schreiben, aber im Kern,
in der Instruktion gibt es eigentlich nur eine einzige Variante und die Sprache
selber ist relativ schlank.
Es gibt da gar nicht viel Dinge, die Datentypen, Es ist alles sehr überschaubar,
keine Objekte, keine Klimbim und deswegen ist es halt sehr vorhersehbar, was es dann tut.
Ja gut, es kommt natürlich immer darauf an, was du damit machen willst.
Du kommst natürlich mit manchen Sprachen in manchen Problemen einfach nicht zum Ziel.
Das ist halt der Punkt.
Shared Space, ich würde das jetzt nicht verteidigen wollen,
aber es gibt halt auch Anwendungen wo wenn du genug Shared Space oder genug
State hast dann kannst du den nicht mehr kopieren um irgendwas zu tun weil dann
geht dir die Performance halt flöten und du musst da irgendwie drum rum kommen also,
im Prinzip alles was mit großen Datenmengen zu tun hat und Medien und naja,
Keine Ahnung.
Texturen in der Grafikkarte oder so. Oder so ein Kram, weißt du?
Also ich meine, das ist halt gut, deswegen wäre es jetzt spannend zu wissen,
was für Probleme sie haben lösen lassen.
Ja, das steht da sicherlich in dem Paper, aber das kann ich dir jetzt nicht wiedergeben.
Weil, wie gesagt, dass zum Beispiel Rust so schlecht abschneidet, finde ich interessant.
Also es schneidet ja deutlich niedriger ab als C++, wobei ich meiner Meinung
nach Rust die eindeutig bessere Sprache ist.
Ich auch, aber mich überrascht es jetzt nicht so, dass es so schlecht abschneidet,
weil es ist wirklich komplex.
Es eliminiert ja auch ganze Klassen von Fehlern.
Es ist wirklich komplex, aber aus Gründen.
Es gibt ja gute Gründe dafür, dass Rust Dinge so macht, wie es das tut,
weil sie wollen halt jedes Quäntchen-Performance aus allem rauskitzeln und quetschen.
Ob das ein guter Ansatz ist? Wahrscheinlich für 99 Prozent der Software nein,
aber wenn du diesen Anwendungsfall hast und das machen möchtest und das Browser
in Rust geschrieben werden, das ergibt ja Sinn.
Und vielleicht werden wir auch irgendwann Betriebssystem-Kernels in Rust sehen.
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht.
Wohingegen, ja, keine Ahnung. Also dass Java zum Beispiel so gut abschneidet, wundert mich eher noch.
Also da hätte ich jetzt auch gesagt Java ist schon auch irgendwie Chaos und
die Sprache ist halt auch so alt, dass sie immer wieder Sachen rangeflanscht
haben, wo man einfach mal sagen müsste, jetzt wäre eigentlich mal Zeit für eine neue Sprache,
zum Beispiel Kotlin gut Kotlin schneidet das deutlich besser ab als Java weil
es halt viele alte Zöpfe abschneidet ja weiß nicht, also es,
Das ist auf jeden Fall mal interessant.
Sie schreiben mir in dem Paper, dass Sie 3.920 verschiedene Problems,
sozusagen den LLMs zum Fraß vorgeworfen haben.
Das ist schon relativ breit gestreut.
Was man halt auch sieht, ist, dass die Multiparadigmen-Sprachen alles nur ins Mittelfeld schaffen.
Also da ist jetzt keine von den Multiparadigmensprachen, die wirklich sehr stark rausguckt.
Das würde jetzt deiner These, dass man da zu viele Möglichkeiten hat,
Dinge zu tun, dann auch entsprechen.
Ja, ich hatte mich gerade gefragt, hast du gesehen, ob sie die veröffentlicht
haben, die Fragen? In dem Repo habe ich sie nämlich nicht gefunden.
Ich habe das Paper auch verlinkt, da müsste es ja eigentlich irgendwie drin sein.
Das Dataset haben sie.
Also es gibt ja ein Repo und da müsste es ja eigentlich alles drin sein Also
das habe ich auch verlinkt.
Gibt da ein Sandbox-Image?
Ja, ich habe gesehen, die haben da so Templates für die jeweiligen Sprachen,
wie sie die Prompts generieren, wo dann steht hier Frage einsetzen im Prinzip,
aber die Fragen selbst habe ich nicht gesehen.
Okay, weiß ich jetzt nicht. Irgendwo wird es sein. Naja, am Ende wollte ich
ja eigentlich nur darauf hinweisen, dass Elixir toll ist.
Das war uns allen vorher schon klar.
Aber auch in der Elixir-Community waren alle sehr überrascht.
Also erstens war sie überrascht, dass sie überhaupt dabei waren.
Vom Ergebnis natürlich dann nochmal extra.
So, was haben wir denn noch? Haben wir überhaupt noch was auf unserer Liste?
Nicht fast alles durch hier.
Hat jemand noch ein Thema?
Ich sehe nur das, was über AI steht noch. Keine Ahnung, ob du darüber reden wolltest.
Achso, ja, da habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht viel Erfahrung. Das ist mir noch
aufgefallen, dass der Rode Kasser hier, der kleine Podcast-Mixer,
der hier steht und gerade fleißig diese Sendung aufnimmt,
ein Update bekommen hat von Rode.
Leider nicht mit den Features, die ich mir gewünscht habe.
Dafür andere Features, die du nicht brauchen kannst?
Dafür andere Features, die ich auch nicht brauche oder zumindest noch nicht
so genau sehe, dass ich die brauche.
Aber trotzdem interessant, dass sie das getan haben. Und zwar haben sie nämlich
den Remote Call quasi direkt ins Mischpult eingebaut.
Also das ist ein Feature, das heißt Call Me.
Okay.
Und ich habe es nicht ausprobiert, aber man kann es ausprobieren.
Es hat so einen Free Tier, also es ist natürlich ein Bezahldienst,
wenn du das so in der Professional-Version nutzen möchtest oder überhaupt ausgiebiger benutzen willst.
Aber es gibt zum Ausprobieren so einen Free-Tier. Aber ich habe es noch nicht
ausprobiert, weil du brauchst ja dann auch eine entsprechende Gegenstelle,
wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe.
Ist das so erstmal von Rodercaster zu Rodercaster. Aber sie benutzen, glaube ich, Standards.
Und ja, dann hast du sozusagen virtuelle Tracks und kannst da irgendwie so drei,
vier Leute direkt im Mischpult quasi remote anrufen über Internet.
Hat das Rodekaster irgendwie einen Ethernet-Port?
Ja. Der hat Ethernet. Der hat Internet und so weiter und alle haben sich schon
gefragt, okay, man könnte noch was anderes außer Firmware-Updates darüber laden, stellt sich raus.
Das haben sie wohl von langer Hand geplant und jetzt gibt es halt irgendwie dieses Call-Me-Ding.
Ich habe es noch nicht so richtig getestet, aber vielleicht ist das ja für manche
Leute interessant und wenn man jetzt einfach nur so von Rodekurser zu Rodekassa
eine Verbindung herstellen will über das Internet. Geht das?
Ja, und das haben die einfach mal frech eingebaut und daran haben sie viel Zeit,
verdingst und vielleicht funktioniert das ja auch gut, ich weiß es nicht.
Also ich finde zuverlässig Software-Updates laden, finde ich schon mal ein bravouröses
Feature, das kriegt nicht jeder hin.
Ich erinnere nur an ein Auto, das nicht ein Software-Update gezogen hat und
dann ging die SOS-Taste nicht mehr.
Ja, also,
Also auf der Webseite übersetzen sie CallMe an einer Stelle mit Ruf mich.
Ruf mich.
Ruf mich an.
Ne, ne, ruf mich.
Ruf mich, ja. Es gibt ein CallMeLight, ein CallMe und ein CallMePro und mit
CallMeLight kannst du irgendwie die zehn Stunden Audio-Calls pro Monat machen.
Und dann kann man das auch noch mit Webbrowsern verbinden. Genau,
es ist nicht nur RodeCaster zu RodeCaster, sondern es gibt auch noch sozusagen als Add-on.
Aber das ist halt alles so ein bisschen Bezahl-Service. Ein bisschen schade, finde ich.
Kann ich zwar verstehen, aber naja, ist halt so.
Und in der Pro-Version hast du dann auch Broadcasting-Tools,
Fully Integrated IP Audio Connect for Third-Party-Calls.
und wie Advanced, SIP, also wir machen offensichtlich SIP und nur in der Pro-Version
hast du so richtig hier so,
Opus und so weiter, also keine Ahnung, was sie da in den anderen Versionen verwenden,
ich kann mir gar nicht vorstellen, dass sie irgendwas anderes als Opus verwenden,
unklar, also ist antestet, ich wollte nur darauf hinweisen und sehr gut,
mehr habe ich dazu nicht zu sagen, aber ich wäre mal ganz froh,
wenn sie bei Rode mal meine Mails lesen würden, weil da stehen echt kluge Sachen drin.
Aber offensichtlich interessiert ihr das nicht.
Ach, dieser Brit Love wieder.
Das ist schlimm, oder? Ja, es ist einfach, keiner hört mehr zu. Alle ignorieren mich.
Das Problem ist, wenn man auf dich hört, darf man gleich zwei bis drei neue Developer einstellen.
Naja, sorgt für Beschäftigung.
Na gut, wenn uns die Themen ausgehen, machen wir heute ein bisschen früher Schluss.
Wir müssen es ja jetzt nicht in alle Ewigkeit hinaustragen.
Du sagst es.
Ja.
Falls dir nicht noch was eingefallen ist, Luca?
Ich habe jetzt gerade nichts.
Okay, gut. Also, wie gesagt, hier jetzt haben wir ganz viel über Elixier geschwärmt.
Wenn ihr da mitschwärmen wollt, schreibt mir eine Mail, wegen dieses Badges.
Und ansonsten hören wir uns dann einfach in ein paar Wochen wieder,
dann wieder mit Ralf. Und dann werden wir auch mal das ganze Messer- Feedback,
aufarbeiten, weil...
Das heißt, bis dahin muss ich mich fit machen in Sachen Messer schlafen?
Nee, das muss Ralf was machen, der hat das Thema ja angeschleppt,
aber ich wollte jetzt das Feedback nicht ohne ihn,
durchgehen, weil er da sicherlich auch sehr viel mehr Meinung dazu hat,
aber es kam so dermaßen viel auf die letzte Sendung, dass ich das hinten anstelle.
Sehr gut.
Genau. Alright, dann machen wir das so. Dann machen wir heute ein bisschen früher Schluss und,
danke an Luca, dass du wieder dabei warst und Wo habe ich denn jetzt hier die
wichtige Taste? Da habe ich die richtige Taste.
Guck mal, wenn man den Regler hochzieht, dann funktioniert das auch.
Alright, Leute. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören bei der Freakshow. Ausnahmsweise mal
eine kürzere Sendung. Wir hatten aber auch schon mal so richtig lange Sendungen.
Das müssen wir ja kompensieren.
So ist das. So läuft das hier im Podcast-Wesen. Wir sagen Tschüss. Bis bald. Tschüss.